Ja, ich hab mir gedacht, es kann ja nicht angehen, dass ich den ganzen Tag nicht den
Stream einschalte, obwohl ja eigentlich heute Morgen Aufwachstream dran gewesen wäre.
Nick, Dankeschön für den Sub, der Kellner Kai ist auch am Start, moin.
Ach ja Leute, ich sag euch, ich bin froh, dass der Corona Kram jetzt so langsam, aber
sicher überwunden ist.
Ich war heute Morgen wieder meine zwei Stunden Wandern, naja Wandern ist vielleicht ein bisschen
übertrieben, rumlaufen durch den Wald war es eher, so eineinhalb, zwei Stunden, das ging
wieder halbwegs, wobei ich immer noch ziemlich im Arsch bin insgesamt im Vergleich zu davor,
aber ja, Brainlag ist auch immer noch da, aber nicht mehr ganz so schlimm wie die letzte
Woche, also ich glaube, ich glaube es geht wieder halbwegs.
Ja und ich schmecke und rieche wieder halbwegs was, also es scheint jetzt, ja außer, dass
ich ziemlich kaputt bin noch und Brainlag hab, es scheint wieder alles so weit aufwärts
zu gehen.
Da, habt ihr ne Ahnung, fällt mir gerade so ein, was ist die längste USB-Verlängerung,
die es gibt?
Moment, muss ich mal kurz, bist da striemlich los, kurz mal Amazon gucken, USB-Verlängerung,
was ist denn die längste, die man so kriegt?
Gibt es da 10 Meter, mein 10 Meter ist vielleicht ein bisschen gar viel, aber, mein es hat
nur 5 Volt, irgendwann kommt halt nix mehr an, ne passt schon, das meiste ist schon erledigt,
meiste hat sich schon erledigt, alles gut, weil wie, was ist das, Melonenman, Melon, Melonman
heißt es, oder?
Dantudev, Dankeschön, 16 Monate Hyper-Subscription, Massive, gibt es, gibt es 10 Meter, 10 Meter
USB-Extension-Kelbe, du, du, du, du, du, du, geht das 10 Meter, oder verreckt das dann,
also verreckt, geht nix kaputt, aber geht das noch, ein Repeater-Kabel, ah das ist was
Aktives, oder?
5 Meter, 5 Meter Passiv, doch kein Lack, ja, ja sowas hier, irgendwas, 5 Meter USB, weil
ich muss im Keller einen Micro-Controller verlängern und ich kann jetzt entweder ein
Kabel an der Decke lang legen, für 5 Volt, mit 2 Adern drin, oder ich nehme halt eben
eine USB-Verlängerung, mach sein USB-Stöpsel, USB-Stecker, stöpsel ich ein, gucken, weil
ich hab doch jetzt einen, ne das bringt mir ja nix, ich muss ja Strom, ich will ja Strom
übers USB übertragen, also ich weiß nicht, ob irgendjemand schon Power-Over-TCP oder
Power-Over-Wi-Fi oder so erfunden hat, weil man könnte mit einem Laser oder so irgendwas
machen, ne ich will eigentlich am besten ohne Repeater, dass es schön dünn bleibt, ja zumindest
ich hab jetzt einen Sensor im Keller für meinen Parkplatz, weiß ich, hab ich euch das schon
erzählt, ich glaub schon, ne, wie heißt dieser Sensor, lass mal kurz gucken, Amazon Ultraschall-Sensor
Wasserfest, ja sowas hier, wobei es nicht exakt, exakt das Ding für, Alter 40 Euro
ist Kekkel, Alter, sowas kostet bei, sowas kostet bei Ali, bei Aliexpress wahrscheinlich,
guckt's euch mal an, Aliexpress kostet das wahrscheinlich 250 oder so, ne Aliexpress
ist teuer geworden, China-Chinesen Kram, naja zumindest hab ich so ein Ding geholt,
das ist ein wasserdichter Ultraschall-Sensor, den kann man außen ans Haus machen und da
mess ich den Abstand von meiner Wand zum Parkplatz und da kann ich erkennen, ob der Parkplatz
vor dem Haus frei ist und das hab ich am Microcontroller im Keller und den hab ich jetzt aktuell ziemlich
eklig mit so einem Verlängerungskabel ans Fenster gepackt und da will ich irgendwas
an der Decke lang machen, deswegen USB-Verlängerung, ja, wisst ihr, vielleicht hab ich's mir auch
einfach gemerkt, ne 5 Meter müssten eigentlich reichen, ich mein ich hab im Keller unten
ja diese schaltbare China-Chinesen Steckdosenleiste, eine von denen die wir letztens hier geflasht
haben, Small Access Point, moin, eine die wir hier geflasht haben, ja so ne Steckdosenleiste
hab ich ja im Keller, so eine da, die da, die hier, die wir geflasht haben und ich kann
ja eh schon ein und ausschalten von oben, ich brauch eigentlich nur noch ne USB-Verlängerung.
Übrigens Abschleppdienst, ich hab gestern ein Abschleppauto gesehen, das hatte den
besten Abschleppdienst Spruch überhaupt drauf, your crash my cash, ich hab mir auch
gedacht, eigentlich ziemlich guter Spruch für den Abschleppdienst oder, your crash
my cash, weiß ich ob die Leute das so lustig finden, die gecrashed sind, achja wo wir grad
dabei sind Leute, Steam Steads, was macht Battlefield so und New World, meine Runde
Ketten, Moment ein ja, ohja Wahnsinn, immerhin nicht so wie vorher, sondern jetzt nicht mal
ganz so schlecht, aber immer noch richtig mies, so und was macht New World, New World
macht, das ist ja sogar noch, noch weniger als ich gedacht hab, Alter, 2, müsst ihr
euch vorstellen, von einer Million aufgerundet, runter auf 22.000, 22k ist doch gut, wenn ja
in Battlefield 2042 Maßstäben vielleicht ja, aber insgesamt ist das abkundtief mies
und was ich immer witzig finde ist, dass da die Leute kommen und sagen, ja ja, aber Max,
es ist doch normal, dass MMOs nach dem Start Spieler verlieren, also erstens guckt euch
mal Final Fantasy an den Verlauf und zweitens, ja mag normal sein, aber das ist schon wirklich
heftig, gucken wir doch mal, 14 Steam, na gut, das ist über Steam jetzt ziemlich beschissen,
weil die eigentlich hauptsächlich gar nicht über Steam gespielt werden, aber trotzdem,
guckt mal hier, die haben kontinuierlich zugelegt, das musste er auch erst mal schaffen für
den MMO, aber gut, die bringen ja auch kontinuierlich Content und kontinuierlich anscheinend guten
Content, den die Leute spielen wollen, das kannst du bei New World so gar nicht sagen,
New World hat ja schon den vierten Server Merch oder so mittlerweile, wo ich meine Schadenfreude
hernehme, ja hauptsächlich daraus, dass beide Games so als neues Erfindung des Rats angepriesen
wurden, ja, ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, als New World ja in die Beta gegangen ist,
ich hab damals ja schon gesagt, also ich hab ganz am Anfang gesagt, New World ist eines
der wenigen MMOs, wo ich mir tatsächlich Chancen ausrechne dafür, aber da war es noch ein
eher PvP-Gillen versus-Gillen orientiertes Spiel und das haben sie ja komplett umgestrickt
in so einem PvP-PvM-Lite-MMO, so eineinhalb Jahre vor Release und da hab ich auch gesagt,
ich bin echt skeptisch, ob das passt, ich hab das ja angespielt in der Alpha und mir
war direkt klar, dass es ein Spiel ohne wirklichen Spielsinn, also ohne Content so wirklich,
es hat alles so lieblos gewirkt, ja, selbst die Einstiegsquests, die eigentlich ja die
Leute bei der Stange halten sollen, waren so, so, so schlechter als Dark Quests von 2001
oder so, also, ja, keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht, also das, und vor allem, also was mich
bei New World ein bisschen schadenfroh sein lässt, sind die ganzen Leute, die wieder
ihren Streamern hinterher gerannt sind, so nach dem Motto, oh, Kronk spielt New World,
best game ever, best game ever, und dann auf Twitter irgendwie sich da die Schlammschlag
geliefert haben, so nach dem Motto, oh nein, er hat mein Mob-Camp weggeklaut, oh nein,
und best game ever, und das war klar, und ich hab damals ja auch auf Twitter schon gesagt,
Leute, ihr werdet euch sehnen nach der Warteschlange, wenn die ersten Server-Merches kommen, und
es ist halt so.
Ja, ganz ehrlich, ich, es hört sich jetzt, okay, ich geb zu, es hört sich jetzt ein
bisschen großkotzig an, und ja, ich hab auch schon, ich hab auch schon komplett falsch
gelegen, ja, also eines der Spiele, wo ich wirklich ins Klo gegriffen habe, mit meinem
Eindruck, war Rainbow Six Siege, ich hab das gespielt in der Beta, und ich hab irgendwie
für das Spiel nicht so viel Zukunft gesehen, man muss aber so zu meiner Rettung sagen,
ich glaube, das haben damals viele nicht gesehen, aber ich hab falsch gelegen, ich hab wirklich
komplett falsch gelegen.
Sie haben sich aber auch richtig Mühe gegeben mit Rainbow Six Siege, wie es in den letzten
zwei, drei Jahren aussieht, weiß ich nicht mehr, aber danach ging es nochmal richtig
gut, guck mal, Rainbow Six Siege, SteamStats, guck mal doch mal, oder spielt man das hauptsächlich
über Uplay?
Kannste dich echt, kannst dich echt nicht beschweren jetzt, wirklich nicht, nicht verkehrt.
Mal kurz die Musik ein bisschen leiser machen, aber einfach hier ein bisschen leiser, Kekkel.
Ja, was wollte ich jetzt sagen, genau, also da hab ich wirklich komplett falsch gelegen
mit meiner Einschätzung zu Rainbow Six Siege, aber bei vielen anderen Sachen hab ich richtig
gelegen und auch wenn sich jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen großkotzig anhört, ich bin mittlerweile
schon, also ich bin mittlerweile so lang am Start, was PC Games und Games an sich betrifft,
ich maße mir einfach an zu sagen, ich kann das relativ gut vor Release einschätzen, ob
das ein Griff ins Klo wird oder nicht.
Ich leg natürlich auch manchmal falsch, aber es gibt so Sachen wie die Beta von New World,
die ich angespiele, da wusste ich, das führt nichts, das war alles so halbherzig und lieblos
und gewollt und nicht gekonnt, gewollt und nicht gekonnt ist glaube ich die beste Zusammenfassung
für New World, die man machen kann, New World ist ein Spiel komplett gewollt, vielleicht
viel gewollt, aber nicht gekonnt und am Geld liegt es ja bei Amazon wirklich nicht, Dankeschön
ZTE für den Prime Sub, Prime Leg, Pog, also und gewollt und nicht gekonnt ist auch ein
sehr gutes, gute Redewendung für Battlefield 2042, weil bei Battlefield 2042, ich hab mir
heute morgen, ich gerade mal kurz, Communications, wie heißen die auf Twitter, Striker, Dankeschön
für den Sub, Corona ist naja vorbei, doch, doch, das zum größten Teil ist vorbei, aber
ein bisschen ist noch, ein bisschen ist noch übrig, also ganz, bin noch nicht, ich hab
heute morgen mal ein bisschen auf diesen Battlefield Communications Channel geguckt, hab festgestellt
die posten ja eigentlich gar nichts mehr und das letzte was ich sinnvollerweise gefunden
habe, oh Gott, Twitter man, ok dann such ich so Battlefield, ich hab ja meinen Blogpost
geschickt zu geheime Änderungen, also wenn das nicht der Ultra Clickbait Titel ist dann
weiß ich auch nicht, zumindest ich hab diesen Blogpost gefunden zu Battlefield 2042 Update
1.2, ich find's immer witzig, wie diese Updates, wie diese Nummern hier irgendwie suggerieren,
das Spiel wäre schon bei 1.0 angelangt, das nächste Update ist dann übrigens 2.0, so
und da ist mir mal wieder eine Sache aufgefallen, dass es genau so gekommen ist, wie ich es
damals 3 Wochen oder so nach dem Release in meinen Videos gesagt hab, die Posten, allen
Ernst, das ist jetzt kein Spaß, wisst ihr um was der Blogpost geht, also die wichtig,
interessanteste Änderung in diesem Blogpost, die interessanteste Änderung ist immer noch,
dass sie sich über neue Kisten auf Kaleidoskop auslasten, Leute das haben die Anfang des
Jahres gepostet, hier steht's doch wieder, Anfang des Jahres, jetzt ernsthaft, die feiern
sich, das muss man sich mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen, die feiern sich dafür, dass
sie Anfang des Jahres gesagt haben, sie überarbeiten die Karten und jetzt, sagen wir mal in der
zweiten Jahreshälfte, kommen sie mit um die Ecke, wir haben auf einer Map ein paar neue
Kisten und LKWs platziert und im gleichen Zug wollen sie uns allen Ernstes erzählen,
DICE arbeitet mit voller Kraft und vollem Team an diesem Spiel, Alter, das ist einfach
so, so abfuck, ist der Wahnsinn, es gibt ja wie gesagt nur zwei Varianten, entweder sie
lügen uns an, DICE arbeitet gar nicht mehr mit dem gesamten Team dran, was ich persönlich
ja eben für am wahrscheinlichsten halte, oder aber sie sind so extremst unfähig, dass
sie selbst mit dem gesamten Team nicht mehr als drei Kisten es schaffen zu platzieren
auf dem, zumindest es gab ein, ja diese Änderung der Specialist und so ein bisschen von der
Technik finde ich ja, ist ja alles in Ordnung, kann man ja machen, aber das rettet das Spiel
jetzt ja auch nicht, das Spiel ist ja auch nicht mehr rettbar, so und dann haben sie
nämlich ein Blog-Post, nee ein YouTube-Video-Blog gepostet, das fand ich auch lustig, das haben
sie ja noch nicht mal drin, das haben sie ja noch nicht mal drin verlinkt, so peinlich
war das, ja es gab nämlich noch ein Video-Blog auf YouTube, da haben sie 45 Minuten mit ein
paar Designern da gesessen, die haben sich wirklich 45 Minuten aus den Dingern aus den
Fingern gesaugt, die sie sagen konnten, ohne wirklich Sinn und Verstand, naja gut, da habe
ich halt auch komplett richtig gelegen, ja aber manchmal greife ich über Sachen bei
Rainbow Six Siege ins Klo, da habe ich falsch gelegen, falsch gelegen mit meiner Einschätzung,
das stimmt, ja es ist ja auch so, Arci, Dankeschön für den Sub, ja kommt ja auch nichts, gibt
ja auch nichts, trotz neuem Battlefield-Chef und Leute die das auf Vordermann bringen wollen
und vollem Commitment, da kann man weiß mal gern was Bittere ist, dass ob so volles Commitment
aussieht oder ob sie uns einfach anlügen, aber die Marketing-Abteilung von DICE beziehungsweise
EA war ja was Battlefield 2042 angeht wirklich nicht schlecht, die haben ihre Arbeit gemacht,
leider war das Produkt dann ziemlich am Müll, na gut, was trendet wo wir gerade dabei sind,
wir gucken uns, wir gucken uns gleich, Leute wenn ihr irgendwas habt, irgendwie was euch
bewegt, schreibt es in den Chat, ich habe mir nichts großartiges überlegt heute, ich
bin noch zu brain-laggy da irgendwelche Programmiersachen, Bastelsachen, Löt-Sachen oder sonst viel
zu machen, wir müssen heute, wir schwätzen heute eineinhalb Stunden oder so bis 21 Uhr,
22 Uhr und dann sollen wir mal gucken, hast du mal ein Linux Foundation Zertifikat gemacht?
Nein, keine Ahnung, ich wusste gar nicht, dass die Linux Foundations Kubernetes Zertifikat
hat, da kannst du ja theoretisch auch irgendwelche Cloud-Anbieter Zertifikate machen, ah da kann
ich gleich was zu sagen, hast du die Videotext Demo von der Evoke, Evokey, Evoke, weiß
ich gar nicht mehr, ne habe ich nicht, zeig mal, was muss ich denn suchen, Videotext, so,
zeig, 420 years of teletext, was bin ich, was bin ich, was bin ich sehend, ist das,
ist das über Videotext ausgestrahlt alles oder wie, krasser Scheiß, was ist mit dem
los, kannst du über Videotext überhaupt so schnell was übertragen, ich wusste auch
gar nicht, dass es Ton kann, ja, nicht schlecht, ah das schöne, das schöne CRT-Flimmern,
manchmal, wisst ihr was man daran relativ gut sieht, was man auch bei alten Konsolenspielen
finde ich ganz gut gesehen hat, technische Beschränkungen sorgen oftmals für, wie soll
ich sagen, gehobene Kreativität, ja, also wenn du technisch nicht alles machen kannst,
dann sorgt das manchmal dafür, dass das Ergebnis so blöds klingt, besser ist, blödes Beispiel
jetzt, ja, fällt mir jetzt gerade ein, weil ich letztens mal wieder Jurassic Park geguckt
hab, also den original, übrigens da gibt es ein mega geiles Video, muss ich euch gleich
mal zeigen, wahrscheinlich kennt ihr das schon, ich hab letztens mal wieder den original Jurassic
Park geguckt und deshalb hab ich mir aufgefallen, was das ausmacht, wenn erstens man nicht
alles mit CGI vollkleistert, weil man es kann, sondern es halt dort einsetzt, wo es sinnvoll
ist und wenn irgendjemand ein Drehbuch geschrieben hat, der sich ein bisschen Gedanken drüber
gemacht hat, ja, das passt alles ziemlich gut zusammen, klar, ich mein gerade, ich mein
diese Jurassic Park Szene, wo der Typ auf dem Klo gefressen wird, ja, das kennen die
meisten wahrscheinlich, das war natürlich schon sehr günstig gefilmt, alles so ein
bisschen im dunklen oder so, aber wirklich gut gemacht und die Effekte in Jurassic Park
sind wirklich gut gealtert, übrigens, hier dieses Video finde ich mega gemacht, der
Typ hat seine Katze in, seine Katze in Jurassic Park rein editiert, muss ich mal kurz zeigen,
richtig, richtig, richtig Pog gemacht, ich mein heute kannst du sowas daheim editieren,
ja, an 115 Rechner, damals hatten wir irgendwelche, mit was haben die nochmal, mit was haben
die nochmal Jurassic Park gemacht, irgendwelche spezielle Workstation Hardware, die, keine
Ahnung, die ein paar Jahre später wegschmeißen konnten, irgendwie ganz, ganz komisches Zeug,
was heute kein Mensch mehr verwendet, Silicon Graphics, ja, das kann, SGI, ja, genau,
stimmt, stimmt, ja, aber das ist wirklich gut hier, das ist richtig gut gemacht, dieser
Spot-Tot vielleicht, ja, ey, da, überlegt euch mal, ihr seid ne Maus, da kriegt ihr
schon, ich mein, guckt euch, stellt euch mal vor, ja, ihr seid ne Maus, sitzt im Mauseloch
und die Katze guckt euch so von draußen an, das ist doch ähnlich zu euch, guckt der T-Rex
ins Auto, ja, da kriegt ihr schon ein bisschen mit Angst zu tun, egal, ich lass es jetzt
zwar durchlaufen, das ist ja nur ne Minute.
Für mich ist dasождier, ganz einfach.
Das ist mega gut gemacht, oder?
Vor allem, vor allem, also der Chat hat schon gesagt, die Beleuchtung ist richtig gut und
vor allem, dass sie auch Katzenfutter und sowas hier haben, das ist richtig, richtig
nice gemacht.
Das ganze gibt es übrigens auch mit Titanic und alles, also Godzilla versus OVL Kitty
und da gibt es total viele Videos, aber richtig gut gemacht.
Aber dann siehst du mal, was du heutzutage mit Videobearbeitung und ein bisschen Effekten
daheim machen kannst.
Natürlich musst du wissen, was du machst, ja, aber schon, schon ziemlich, ziemlich gut.
Ja, was wollte ich jetzt sagen, es ist mir, ja es ist mir letztens wieder aufgefallen,
also der originale Jurassic Park ist wirklich gut gealtert und mir ist mal wieder aufgefallen,
als ich letztens geguckt habe, wie wenig Dinosaurier in Jurassic Park drin sind im ersten Teil
und die sind halt genau richtig platziert, also der hat schon Dinosaurier, ja, aber es
ist nicht total zu, also ich würde sagen, von Jurassic Park 1 ist gut 60% ohne Dinosaurier
und vielleicht sogar 70%.
Ja, also richtig, also richtig nice, also falls den Film noch jemand nicht gesehen hat,
kann ich auch immer noch empfehlen, ist wirklich immer noch ein guter Film und vor allem halt,
als nicht komplett vollgekleistert ist mit CGI, sondern wirklich, du merkst halt, da
hat irgendjemand dahinter gesessen, der sich ein bisschen Gedanken gemacht hat.
Das war nicht, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, das war eine, Jurassic Park 1 waren die Effekte
eine Mischung aus, aus, oh je, waren die Effekte eine Mischung aus CGI, also diese T-Rex-Chase-Scene
war CGI, komplett, aber viele Nahaufnahmen waren noch Roboter, ey, ich hab mir die letzten
gar nicht mehr angeguckt, ähm, wusste ich nicht, aber kann sein, dass ich schon mal
in irgendeinem Fun-Fact-Video gesehen hab, bestimmt, bestimmt, äh, was, hier hat eben
gerade jemand was gefragt, Hi Wupplos, machst du als.NET-Dev eigentlich gar keinen Freundheit
über JS?
Doch, mach ich, haben wir doch im Stream schon oft genug gemacht, aber erst, wo ich sag,
ich bin ja hauptberuflich gar kein.NET-Entwickler, ich mag halt einfach.NET und mach viel in
.NET, hauptberuflich bin ich, was man neu Deutsch nennt, DevOps-Engineer, weil sich
es cooler anhört, und ich hab da auch ein Video zu gemacht, wenn du es genau wissen
willst, ich hab grad überlegt, ob ich noch ein bisschen ausführlich erzählen soll,
aber nee, ich hab ein Video zugemacht, ich hab schon so oft, ich muss euch nicht immer
den gleichen Krämpel erzählen, ähm, ja, also normalerweise mach ich ja was anderes,
aber natürlich ist da auch nicht schlecht, wenn man ein bisschen programmieren kann
und ein bisschen Ahnung von Software-Entwicklung hat, und doch, ich mach relativ viel Frontend-Java-Skript-Zeug,
wenn du mal guckst, auch im Archiv und auch hier in den Wots, wir haben relativ viel Java-Skript-Zeug
schon gemacht, allerdings, muss ich sagen, Angular noch gar nicht und React auch noch
nicht, wir haben hauptsächlich Svelte gemacht in letzter Zeit und Vue.js, und nachdem ich
jetzt zwei Frontend-Frameworks halbwegs kann, seh ich jetzt nicht noch ein oder zwei andere
zu lernen, und gerade auf Angular hab ich wirklich keinen Bock, hast du schon was mit
GitLab-Pipelines gemacht, nein, mit GitLab-CI hab ich so gut wie gar nichts gemacht bis
jetzt und, ähm, mit, dementsprechend mit GitLab-Pipelines auch nicht. Ich kenne Jenkins-Pipelines,
für die Boomer unter uns, falls das jemand kennt, Jenkins-Pipelines, ich kenn mich ganz
gut mit GitHub-Actions aus, aber mit GitLab-CI nicht, aber ganz ehrlich, das was ich gesehen
hab von GitLab-CI war jetzt nicht so, sah jetzt nicht so kompliziert aus, du musstest
irgendwelche Runners installieren und Jaml-Config für machen. Du kennst nur Leroy Jenkins,
ja, ey, das ist auch so ein Ding, das hätt ich auch nicht gedacht, dass ich das noch
irgendwie 20 Jahre lang hält, das war ja auch 2005 oder so. Ja, was macht die Stellensuche,
also ich hatte eigentlich letzte, theoretisch hatte ich verabredet, kann man nicht sagen,
letzte Woche, Montag, Probearbeiten, mal kennenlernen, gucken wie das ist, wie
gesagt, ich hab mich ja immer noch nicht entschieden, ob ich jetzt wo Neues hingehe, aber ich guck
mich halt weiterhin um und das musste ich wegen Corona verschieben, ansonsten gibt's
noch nix Neues. Wie gesagt, mit GitLab-CI-CD, wenn man das cool ausspricht, also GitLab-Continuous
Integration, Continuous Delivery Pipelines, genau, und so hab ich noch nix gemacht. Aber
wie gesagt, es sah jetzt erstmal so, ich hab da mal ein Tutorial drüber geguckt, jetzt
nicht so wahnsinnig kompliziert aus. Ich bin nicht arbeitslos, nö. Ich hab meinen
ganz normalen Job noch, aber ich bin grad ein bisschen mich am umgucken, was es noch
so gibt, weil es gibt einige Sachen, die mich an meinem aktuellen Job ziemlich nerven, zum
Beispiel, dass sie in letzter Zeit so pingelig geworden sind, was Homeoffice angeht und die
Leute jetzt teilweise wieder 2-3 Tage die Woche ins Büro sollen und so was, manche
sollen sogar 80% ins Büro und so was. Tja. Soll ich noch mehr? Was? Was auch immer, wir
können jetzt noch mehr Tabs aufmachen, ja. Ja, also, wie gesagt, ich bin nicht arbeitslos,
aber ich bin am gucken. Was wollte ich jetzt noch sagen? Ich wollte, ich weiß nicht,
Brain Lag, ich sag doch Brain Lag, ich wollte noch irgendwas zu dem, was ich da vorgesagt
hab, loswerden. Aber ich weiß nicht mal was. Wie läuft's mit dem Brain Lag? Du bist gerade
rechtzeitig gekommen, es laggt. Du hast ja eine Ausbildung zum Fachinformatiker Systemintegration
gemacht. Ja, naja, ich hab schon immer, also, ich hab ein Video zugemacht, ja, da hab ich
glaub ich auch ein bisschen erzählt, wie sich das alles ergeben hat. Also, ich hab schon
immer gerne programmiert, ich hab auch schon immer gerne mich mit Automatisierung und solchen
Sachen beschäftigt. Und irgendwann kam dann halt mal der Tag, wo wir gesagt haben, hey,
das war, das war sogar noch zu der Zeit, wo ich beim Provider mich um Nagios, weiß ich
noch, Nagios, ich hab mir eine ganze Zeit lang riesen Nagios-Installationen betreut, das
ist aber schon ewig her. Irgendwann kam dann mal der Zeitpunkt, wo wir gesagt haben, hey,
wir müssen uns mal ein bisschen damit beschäftigen, unsere Server automatisiert aufzubauen. Und
da haben wir damals, angefangen damals noch mit Puppet, falls das noch jemand kennt, ähm,
mit Puppet Server zu automatisieren und da haben wir angefangen mit, ja, wie machen
wir das jetzt mit dem Source-Code, dann hatten wir erstmal ganz kurz ein SVN-Repo, haben
festgestellt, SVN sackt, SVN ist richtig. Und dann haben wir Git genommen und da hab
ich mir angefangen ziemlich intensiv ein paar Monate lang mit Git zu beschäftigen, was
gerade am Anfang aufgrund der fehlenden Beispiele gar nicht so einfach war. Und da ging das
Ganze eigentlich immer weiter von, ja, okay, jetzt haben wir ganz viele Server automatisiert,
jetzt haben wir einen Repo mit den ganzen Automatisierungs-Sachen drin, jetzt müssen
wir das Ganze ja auch irgendwie testen, jetzt müssen wir sicherstellen, dass die neuesten
Configs auch immer auf die Systeme drauf kommen, dann müssen wir gucken, dass das Ganze vielleicht
noch ein ordentliches Change-Log bekommt, wo man nachgucken kann, dann haben wir angefangen
mit Pull-Requests oder Merch-Requests eigentlich, haben wir mit Pull-Requests angefangen, haben
wir mit Code-Reviews angefangen und, ja, das hab ich mehr oder weniger alles etabliert
bei uns auf der Arbeit und das war schon quasi DevOps, bevor es das Wort DevOps gegeben hat.
Das hat sich so ergeben und hauptsächlich eigentlich aus dem Grund, weil ich schon immer
gerne Sachen automatisiert hab und mich schon immer ein bisschen für Software-Entwicklungen
programmieren und Quellcode-Verwaltung und solche Sachen interessiert hab.
Ja, ist ja bei vielem so, ist ja bei vielen Sachen so, ne, also einfach reinkommen, dass
man das gut benutzen kann, ist ja bei vielen Sachen einfach, aber dass man einen kompletten
Durchblick hat, ist ja bei vielen Dingern dann teilweise gar nicht möglich. Ich mein,
guckt euch mal Windows Active Directory an. Windows Active Directory ist ja so das beste
Beispiel für, kann jeder irgendwie benutzen, Ahnung davon hat keiner, wahrscheinlich nicht
mal Microsoft selbst. Doch, kanns, aber es ist ja nicht verboten,
also ich mein, ich hab das sogar auf der Arbeit sogar gesagt, dass ich mir umgucke, je nachdem
was die da jetzt mit Homeoffice machen. Ich mein es ist ja kein Geheimnis, das heißt
ja nicht, dass ich jetzt irgendwie auf der Arbeit Scheiße baue oder so. Aber ganz davon
ab gehts, also wenn das jetzt dort irgendjemand nicht gefällt, was soll ich machen ja. Sie
könnten auch genauso gut sagen, wir ändern was dran, werden sie aber wahrscheinlich nicht
machen. Ne, das gibt's, das geht bei uns glaube ich
eher nicht durch. Ja, mit CheckMK hab ich nie was gemacht,
aber Nagios hab ich mal ganz lang betreut. Ja, es ist auch so. Es ist auch so. Also ich
sag euch jetzt mal wie das bei uns gewesen ist. Es sind schon einige Leute komplett weg,
ich weiß von Leuten die zum Ende des Jahres gehen, vielleicht je nachdem was kommt, vielleicht
ich auch. Wie gesagt, ich bin nicht so wirklich scharf drauf, aber die erste Sache die ich
jetzt hier so bei meiner, ich kann es auch nicht mal Suche nennen, über die ich so zufällig
drüber gestolpert bin, muss ich sagen ist wirklich eine Sache die mir gut gefällt und
wenn das so mit dem Probearbeitstag sich bestätigt und man sich am Ende dann auch noch auf ein
gutes Gehalt einigt und das alles passt, überlege ich mir das schon ernsthaft.
Oh, CVN ist wirklich, wirklich ganz, ganz schrecklich. CVN ist das wo die Leute sich
immer Ordner kopiert haben anstatt zu Merchen. Papa das seh ich mal, nein überhaupt nicht,
der heiße Shit ist jetzt entweder Ansible, wenn du so die klassische Server Automatisierung
haben willst oder wenn du Cloud Native Web 3.0, ne ach keine Ahnung, mir fällt jetzt nichts
gescheites an. Wenn du was moderneres verwenden willst, wo du nicht so viel Server Konfiguration
brauchst, sondern mehr Server Provisioning, dann ist Terraform jetzt sehr angesagt. Man
muss sagen es sind eigentlich beides komplett unterschiedliche Tools, also auch wenn es
total viele Artikel gibt, Terraform versus Ansible. Das ist aber eigentlich ziemlicher
Blödsinn, ich glaube das hier trifft ganz gut, weil Terraform ist eigentlich ein Tool
dafür um Server Infrastruktur anzulegen und Ansible ist ein Tool um Server Infrastruktur
zu konfigurieren. Man kann mit beidem beides bis zu einem gewissen Punkt machen, aber
man merkt die Schwerpunkte eindeutig. Also wenn man viele Server hat die längere Zeit
Leben und State haben und konfiguriert werden müssen, ist Ansible sicher besser als ein
bisschen Cloud Init über Terraform oder vielleicht ein paar Shell Befehle, aber wenn du beispielsweise
Server Infrastrukturen gerne reproduzierbar aufbaubar hast und wegwerfen willst und wieder
anders wo hin stellen willst, dann ist Terraform das bessere. Also Terraform ist auf jeden
Fall das deutlich angesagtere Tool aktuell. Warum bist du eigentlich nirgendswo angemeldet?
Du meinst hier im Browser? Da müsste ich mich mit irgendeinem Account hier anmelden,
was ich mit einem Stream Account nicht machen will. Ja, SVNS. Was, wie hieß das andere
was vor SVN war? CSV oder so? Nee, CVS? Kann das sein? CVS? Das ist noch abartiger.
Das ist noch ekliger als SVN. Leute, ich sag euch Shit ist das einzig wahre Versionsverwaltungssystem.
Weiß ich, gibt es jemand von euch, der noch, wie heißt das Ding? Wie heißt dieses Microsoft
Ding nochmal? Wie heißt dieses Ding nochmal? Team Foundation Server benutzen muss. Hat
jemand die Ehre von euch, ja? Ja, Bazaar gibt es da noch und es gibt ja jede Menge Kölfer,
aber ich sag euch Leute, Shit ist das beste was es gibt aus mehreren Gründen. Erstens
ist es dezentral und ganz gut durchdacht und es ist verbreitet. Du findest Leute, das ist
ja eh das wichtigste. Es bringt dir ja meistens gar nichts, wenn du die super geilste, neueste
moderne Technik verwendest, wenn du keine Leute findest, die das verwenden können.
Also Git ist verbreitet. Du kannst von jedem Entwickler heutzutage erwarten, dass er sich
mit Git insoweit auskennt, dass er seine Features als Pull-Request aufmachen kann oder als Merch-Request
und das ist eigentlich das wichtigste. Und ansonsten kannst du damit mehr oder weniger
alles machen, was du so brauchst. Das einzige, was in Git nicht gut funktioniert, der aktuelle
Trend geht ja zum Monorepo. Warum eigentlich? Weil Facebook gesagt hat, das ist gut glaube
ich. Also sprich, dass man quasi mehrere Projekte, die thematisch zusammengehören, in ein Repo
packt und dann auch alles mögliche dazu packt. Also was Git nicht gut kann ist Binaries,
aber dafür gibt es ja mittlerweile schon Abhilfe. Da gibt es ja schon verschiedene Zusatztools,
dass man das außerhalb von Git abspeichern und trotzdem im Repo drin stehen hat und sowas.
Also Binaries speichern in Git geht kann man machen, aber wenn die Binaries sich öfters
ändern, wird das Repo sehr schnell sehr groß und langsam. Ansonsten rein mit Source Code
kannst du Git eigentlich nahezu nicht in die Knie zwingen. Selbst mit tausenden Branches
und Comets und so ist das, juckt das überhaupt nicht. Git LSF gibt es, es gibt noch ein paar
mehr Sachen in der Richtung. Ja, du bist nicht der einzige. Pog, dieses Jahr? Geht's los?
Was ist Clear Case? Kenn ich nicht. Rational Clear Case. Ist das ein proprietäres Git quasi?
Ihh, ok, das ist was uraltes, was glaube ich keiner verwenden will. Der echte Max? Nee,
nee, nee. Der echte Wubblos. Kommst du da drauf? Kenn ich nicht. Also das sagt mir
nix. Aber allein schon, dass es ein IBM Tool ist, lässt mich nichts Gutes vermuten. Ist
das dein dritter Job? Du meinst neben dem was ich mache und YouTube oder was? Leute,
ich hab, ich will viel zu viele Sachen machen, das ist ganz furchtbar schlimm. Neben YouTube,
neben Stream, neben arbeiten, neben meinem Haus rumgebaut mit Automatisierung, hab ich
übrigens überlegt, was ich nicht machen werde. Ich sag's euch nur, was ich nicht
machen werde. Ich wollte mit einem Arbeitskollegen, mit dem hab ich schon ein paar ein oder andere
kleinere Projekte gemacht. Beispielsweise haben wir mal so ein Prototyp für so ne Routenplanungssoftware
gebaut für ein Handwerkerbetrieb, bei dem, dass der da konnte eintippen, ich möchte
um 12.50 Uhr da sein. Also wir haben die Routenplanung nicht selbst programmiert, wir haben was
fertiges genommen und haben einen GUI drauf gesetzt auf die Routenplanung. Ich hab keine
Routenplanung mit Timeslots oder so programmiert, nicht dass es jetzt krasser klingt als es
ist. Haben einen GUI oben drauf gesetzt für die, dass der eintragen konnte, ich möchte
um 12.30 Uhr zu Frau Meyer und um 3.00 Uhr dahin und um 14.00 Uhr dahin. Wir haben zwei
Autos, dann konnte der dann quasi von dieser Routenplanungsoftware sich den optimalen Fahrplan,
also welchen Kunde in welcher Reihenfolge konnte der sich dann, ja da, vor, also suggesten
lassen. Ja so ein paar Kleinigkeiten hab ich mit dem schon gemacht und wir haben uns halt
überlegt, ob wir nicht tatsächlich mal irgendwie eine UG oder so gründen sollen für so kleine
Sachen, aber ich hab keine Zeit, ich krieg das nicht hin. Ich hab nur 24 Stunden am Tag
Zeit und außerdem will ich noch ein paar Sachen machen, die vielleicht nicht vom Computer
sitzen sind. Also es ist wirklich echt nicht einfach, weil man so viel Zeug machen will,
wenn man nicht genug Zeit hat alles zu machen. Ja, Leute, ich weiß es hört sich jetzt von
mir vielleicht ein bisschen blöd an, aber seitdem ich angefangen hab mich regelmäßig
zu bewegen, will ich das nicht mehr aufhören, weil ich hab 15 Kilo abgenommen, weiß ich
warum ich jetzt 15 Kilo getippt hab, aber ich hab 15 Kilo abgenommen seit Anfang des
Jahres seit Februar. Also ich hab angefangen, ich hab doch ab und zu hier mal ein paar Updates
gepostet, guck mal ihr kennt das doch. Guck mal hier Wagenupdate 93,85, heute Morgen hatte
ich Wagenupdate 93,35, 93,35. Angefangen hab ich mal bei, weiß ich gar nicht ob ich
euch die allerersten Sachen sogar schon gepostet hab, glaube ich hab ich am Anfang gar nicht
gepostet. 96 waren wir hier noch, 97,6, 98,5, 99,4, da hatte ich grad die 100 gepackt, glaube
vorher hab ich nie was gepostet, kann das sein? Ne vorher hab ich nichts mehr gepostet. Ich
trinke keine Cola, ne. Naja zumindest, aber guck mal wär das nicht cool, wenn es einfach
mal wieder schneien würde. Leute ihr werdet es nicht glauben, ich war gestern Eis essen
und die Eisverkäuferin hat zu mir gesagt, ich bin ja auch schmal geworden im Gesicht,
also da kann man sich vorstellen, es ist vielleicht auch nicht Gigachat Niveau, aber da kann man
sich vorstellen, also man siehts auf jeden Fall schon, ich mein wenn das einfach so der
random Eisverkäuferin auffällt ja, nicht verliebt die ist, die ist keine Ahnung 75 oder so,
die ist Oma als Verkäuferin. Jaja klar sieht man das, weil mir fällt das persönlich jetzt
nicht so auf, weil ich gucke jeden Tag mal ins Spiegel, aber insgesamt was ich auch gemerkt
hab ist, was ich auch gemerkt hab, gerade während ich Corona hatte, da hab ich ja noch
ein paar Kilo weniger gehabt, weil halt zu wenig gegessen und da hatte ich mal so das
Unterhemd hochgehoben und hab so gedacht Max ey du hast schon ein richtiges Loch im Bauch,
nicht wirklich aber im Vergleich zu früher. Ja also 15 Kilo ist wirklich spürbar und
ich sag euch eine Sache, die man ganz besonders spürt ist, insgesamt gar nicht so sehr die
15 Kilo abgenommen, sondern was man merkt ist, dass das mehr bewegen ist tatsächlich das
was man merkt, also sprich ich würd sagen diese 15 Kilo die ich abgenommen hab, bis
jetzt, ich hoffe ja ich schaffs irgendwie unter 90 bis Ende des Jahres, diese 15 Kilo
die ich abgenommen hab, das ist ja eher so die Folge da draus, dass ich mich halt schlichter
begreifend mehr bewege und vielleicht ein bisschen weniger fett ich esse, aber was ich nicht mach
ich mach keine Diät in dem Fall, also es ist nicht so, es ist nicht so, dass ich irgendwie
super krass die Diätplaner so hätte, weil ich hab in der Vergangenheit schon ein paar
mal versucht abzunehmen mit weniger essen oder anders oder was sag ma mal, deutlich
anderes essen zu essen, das hat nicht geklappt, ich muss meine ordentlichen Portionen fressen
sonst bin ich nicht happy, sonst klappt das nicht. Das einzige was ich jetzt gemacht hab
ist ich versuch es halt nicht fettiger zu machen als es unbedingt sein muss, also wenns
sag ma mal wenns vielleicht Kartoffelbrei gibt mit irgendwas dabei, dann muss der Kartoffelbrei
vielleicht nicht mehr extra angebraten werden davor noch ja, aber insgesamt esse ich mehr
oder weniger den gleichen Kram wie vorher, aber halt ein bisschen weniger fett ich und
was es bei mir halt wirklich ausmacht ist, dass ich mich jeden Tag eineinhalb bis zwei
Stunden mindestens rumlaufen gehe durch den Wald, über Berg und Tal, eher zwei Stunden
halt wo es hügelig ist, acht, neun Kilometer und das bringt tatsächlich was und es bringt
nicht nur fürs Abnehmen was, es bringt vor allem auch was für Kopfschmerzen, Rückenprobleme,
generell so allgemeines, allgemeines Wohlbefinden, ich hatte früher beispielsweise relativ viel
Rückenschmerzen und teilweise so Rückenschmerzen, dass es mir bis ins Bein gezogen hat, also
ich konnte da teilweise gar nicht mehr richtig auftreten und so, weil ich zu viel auf dem
Arsch gesessen hab im Endeffekt und jetzt seitdem ich da jeden Tag, ok manchmal, sonntags
manchmal nicht, aber heute war ich auch wieder, meine eineinhalb, zwei Stunden am Tag laufen
gehe, also laufen, ich meine wirklich laufen, nicht joggen, sondern laufen, ist das wirklich
viel besser alles, also kann ich nur empfehlen, ich hätte mir selbst, hätte ich mir das selbst
gesagt vor 15 Jahren, ja, mit Pan 20, hätte ich gesagt, Max halt die Klappe, Alter, was
willst du von mir, aber es ist tatsächlich so, ein bisschen Bewegung bringt enorm viel,
es müssen keine eineinhalb Stunden, eineinhalb Stunden oder gar zwei Stunden am Tag sein,
es reicht schon, wenn ihr euch eine halbe Stunde mal sinnvoll bewegt am Tag, dass vieles
besser, besser ist als vorher, ja leider, ich verstehe nicht, warum es so viele Boomer-Unternehmen
in Deutschland gibt, die der Meinung sind, das geht nur vor Ort, man hört dann, teilweise
bei uns, wisst ihr was sie bei uns teilweise wirklich als Begründung gebracht haben, die
haben gesagt, ja, also die Leute sollen jetzt ins Büro, weil wir wollen ja vorbeugen, dass
die Leute daheim vereinsamen und psychische Probleme kriegen, also sie tun uns noch was
Gutes, dass man wieder ins Büro muss, alles klar, ich weiß, dass das so krass ist, Leute,
jetzt mal ernsthaft, wie jeder Kabum früher gesagt, Hand aufs Herz, wir sind online erprobt,
wir können auch den Tag verbringen mit Leuten online, wir brauchen nicht zwangsläufig das
Großraumbüro, und mal davon abgesehen, ja, ich bezweifle gar nicht, dass es Leute gibt,
wo das ein Problem ist, aber deswegen das pauschal in Raum zu stellen, so wie man möchte
alle davor beschützen, ist halt einfach nur ein riesen Vorwand, um zu sagen, ja, wir sind
eigentlich zu Boomer, das anders zu machen, das ist so, ja, das ist tatsächlich so, das
ist so ein Spruch, den sagen sie bei uns auf der Arbeit auch gerne, aber ich glaube so
richtig verinnerlicht haben sie es selbst nicht, ja, das ist tatsächlich so, also ich
hab ja selbst nur am Rande jetzt gesucht und ohne großartig zu gucken schon ein paar Sachen
am Start gehabt, ein Kollege von mir hat tatsächlich den etwas größeren Bogen gemacht, hat sich
ein LinkedIn-Account gemacht und hat gemeint, also, der kriegt heute noch am Tag irgendwie
fünf Anfragen, obwohl er schon längst wieder reingeschrieben hat, das will nix mehr, ja,
also da wirst du wohl zu, da ist natürlich auch viel Müll dabei, aber da wirst du zugespammt
ohne Ende, eh, ist so, das kann ich übrigens auch nicht verstehen, es gibt bei uns Leute
auf der Arbeit, die müssen tatsächlich konzentriert an Software arbeiten, ja, also, man könnte
sagen, die programmieren, wobei mir das immer schwer fällt, wenn ich teilweise sehe, wie
unsere Software ausschaut, aber ja, die machen sowas wie programmieren, aber vielleicht ist
unsere Software auch in so einem fragwürdigen Zustand, weil die Leute sich nicht konzentrieren
können, weil die im Büro sitzen, im Großraumbüro sitzen, wo die Leute permanent schwätzen,
telefonieren, Leute durchlaufen, wir haben ja sogar Großraumbüros, die Zwischenbüros
sind zu anderen Großraumbüros, da laufen permanent Leute durch, das ist so schlecht
durchdacht, da kannst du dich nicht konzentrieren, das funktioniert überhaupt nicht, ich hab
meine Noise-Cancelling-Kopfhörer auf, aber selbst dann, und ich sitz schon ziemlich in
der Ecke, ich hab ja, ich habe den letzten Eckenplatz bei uns da, wo keiner eigentlich
mich sieht auf den ersten Blick, darfst du fragen, was Narios ist, klar darfst du fragen,
Narios ist eine Monitoring-Software, Narios, Monitoring-Software, damit kann man Server
überwachen oder generell, müssen keine Server sein, damit kannst du Systeme überwachen,
da kannst du zum Beispiel gucken, pingt das System noch, also es ist hochgefahren, du
kannst mit einem Agent drauf auslesen, ist noch genug Plattenplatz, ist noch genug ram-frei,
läuft der Ram beispielsweise langsam voll, dann kannst du definieren, ab welcher Schwelle
du eine Warnung kriegst, ab welcher Schwelle du einen Fehler kriegst, du kannst gucken,
ob die Anwendungen darauf noch laufen, die laufen sollen, ob Ports offen sind, ob SSH
noch läuft, kannst also deine Systeme überwachen, ob die in einem Zustand sind, wie du das haben
willst und Narios ist eines der ganz, ganz oldschool Softwares dafür, ich mein man sieht
es ja, Softwares, gibt es das Wort überhaupt, man sieht es ja daran, Programmiersprachen
Pearl und CE, Alter, da weißt du Bescheid, tja, der Eason Girlstead hat das entwickelt,
so von ihm hab ich ja nie was gehört, aber das ist anscheinend der Narios Erfinder, so
sieht das Webinterface aus, das Webinterface sieht btw. heute immer noch so aus wie 2001,
aber Narios ist, ich hab ein Herz für Narios, wahrscheinlich weil ich lange Zeit relativ
große Narios beim Provider damals auch relativ große Narios Installationen betreut hab und
ich musste damals, fällt mir grad lustige, lustige Geschichte am Rande ein, ich musste
damals supporten, Debian-Systeme, Ubuntu hat damals noch keiner gehabt, Debian-Systeme,
Red Hat-Systeme und, zahlt euch fest, Suze-Enterprise-Systeme und man denkt sich jetzt eigentlich, ja gut
zwischen so einem Red Hat und so einem Suze-Enterprise ist es ja gar kein großer Akt, doch es ist
ein großer Akt, weil der Narios Agent, den gab es damals nicht für Suze-Enterprise und
ich musste damals diesen Narios, diesen NAPE-Agent oder wie das Ding hieß, damals selbst kompilieren
und RPMs bauen für Suze-Enterprise Linux, seitdem hasse ich Suze-Enterprise Linux, also
RPM bau, ich weiß nicht ob jemand von euch schon mal RPMs mit Speckfiles und sowas bauen
musste, das ist wirklich, also das reicht eigentlich noch gar nicht, das ist eigentlich,
haben wir noch was anderes, haben wir irgendwie noch was anderes, ich weiß nicht, haben wir
noch was anderes, MonkaS, also es ist extrem MonkaS, RPM-Pakete für Suze zu bauen, warum
kein Check per SSH auf die Kitsche, kann man auch machen, kann man auch machen, aber vieles
ist mit dem Agent einfacher, gerade was RAM-Auslastung, CPU-Auslastung und sowas angeht, weil über
SSH musst du ja den Check dann theoretisch selbst programmieren, dann müsstest du dann
in SSH Shell-Skript machen, was das auswertet, das ist mit einem Agent auf dem System deutlich
einfacher, außerdem sind SSH-Checks absolut crap was Performance angeht im Nagios, SSH-Checks
machen den Nagios abartig langsam, zumindest war das damals so, also wenn ihr in Frankfurt
seid geht ihr wahrscheinlich auf die Werner von Siemens Berufsschule, ja sehe ich auch
so, das ist ja auch so ein Ding, was ich auch in meinem Video schon öfters gesagt habe,
es bringt gar nichts, wenn man, wie soll ich sagen, was weiß ich, wenn man mal, wenn
man eine Physi-Ausbildung gemacht hat, das alleine bringt ja noch gar nichts, man muss
schon ein bisschen Ahnung haben, also wenn wir jetzt sagen, wer eine Physi-Ausbildung
gemacht hat und in der Physi-Ausbildung hat man halt nix anderes gemacht, außer Telefone
und Drucker zu konfigurieren, wird es halt danach schwierig was zu finden, man braucht
schon gewisse Schwerpunkte, natürlich gut ist es, wenn Schwerpunkte sind, die auch gefragt
sind, es gibt natürlich so Evergreens, ich sag jetzt nicht Kobol programmieren oder
sowas, aber es gibt so ein paar Sachen, die werden natürlich immer in gewisser Weise
gebraucht, du wirst immer Leute brauchen, die Linux-Systeme administrieren, auch wenn
gesagt wird, ja Server-Administration ist tot, das ist ja alles in der Cloud, Leute,
das ist alles nur die halbe Wahrheit, erstens, das offensichtlichste ist, auch in der Cloud
gibt es irgendwelche Server, die administriert werden müssen, klar, das meistens dann halt
vom Cloud-Anbieter und die brauchen nicht so viele Leute, aber diese Sache mit, ah heute
ist alles in der Cloud, ist meist, kommt meistens von Leuten, die eigentlich gar keine Ahnung
haben, was sie eigentlich in der Cloud betreiben, das sind dann irgendwelche Stonks-Management-Leute,
die sagen, wir machen Cloud-Only-Strategien und Cloud und hier und alles Cloud und in
Wirklichkeit haben sie einfach ihre Hardware-Kisten umgezogen auf VMs in der Cloud, das hat dann
mit Cloud nicht sonderlich viel zu tun und solche VMs in der Cloud brauchst du nach wie
vor immer noch Leute, die sich mit Linux auskennen, also Leute, die ordentlich Linux-Kentnisse
haben, ordentlich Linux administrieren können, wirst du immer brauchen, vielleicht nicht
ganz so viel wie noch vor 10, 15 Jahren, aber immer noch genug und gerade, davon auch nicht
vergessen, gerade in Deutschland, Europa, was DSG, VO und alles angeht, viele Sachen,
ist auch schwierig mit Cloud, also das wirst du immer brauchen, also klassische System-Administration,
auch wenn das irgendwie seit ein paar Jahren so tot gesagt wird, ist nicht tot und wird
wahrscheinlich auch nie tot sein, irgendeiner muss den Kram immer noch betreiben und dann
ist es von unschätzbarem Vorteil, man hat nicht nur ein paar Programmierer, die nebenbei
immer ein paar Docker-Container starten können, sondern Leute, die wirklich Ahnung von Linux
haben, genauso umgedreht, wenn du Leute brauchst, die gut, sagen wir irgendwie eine.NET-Anwendung
entwickeln, ist es auch gut, wenn du wirklich Entwickler hast, die Ahnung haben von dem,
was sie machen und nicht irgendwelche Leute, die hobbymäßig mal ein paar Scripts gebastelt
haben und meinen, wir machen jetzt eine Web-Anwendung draus, also es ist immer wichtig, Leute zu
haben, die Ahnung haben von ihrem Bereich und davon gibt es, man glaubt es nicht, viel
zu wenige, es gibt Leute, die ein bisschen Ahnung haben, also wenn du jemanden suchst,
der mal ein bisschen in Windows rumgeklickt hat und mal ein bisschen AD gemacht hat oder
mal ein bisschen Linux oder mal ein bisschen, da findest du Leute, die Ahnung haben oder
im Zweifelsfall auch mal rausfinden, was der Fehler ist, wenn was im Arsch ist, davon gibt
es nicht viel und davon brauchst du eigentlich immer mehr Leute, als es gibt, ja, also deswegen,
ich kann eigentlich nur sagen, wenn man sich mit dem beschäftigt, worauf man Bock hat und
da richtig gut wird, ist nur von Vorteil, weil dann ist die Chance, dass man in dem Bereich
arbeiten kann, was einem eben Spaß macht, höher und dadurch hat man noch mehr Expertise
und noch mehr Ahnung von, wie sagt man heutzutage so schön, es ist gut, wenn man T-Shaped aufgestellt
ist, nicht T-Shirt, T-Shaped, also sprich, was damit gemeint ist, ist, man hat von vielem,
man hat von vielem ganz gut Ahnung, aber von manchen hat man in der Tiefe Ahnung, deswegen
T-Shaped, also wenn ihr mal irgendwie ein cooles Basswörter braucht, dann könnt ihr
sagen, dass ihr T-Shaped-Knowledge habt oder sowas, also das ist nicht verkehrt, wenn man
ein bisschen Ahnung hat, aus allen Bereichen, ja, aber wenn man dann in eins, zwei, vielleicht
drei Bereichen wirklich tiefgreifend Ahnung hat.
X-Shaped, naja, das sind die gleichen Leute, die auch diagonal skalieren, weil horizontal
und vertikal nicht mehr ausreicht, weiß gar nicht, ob es das überhaupt wirklich schon
irgend einer erzählt hat, das müssen wir echt mal etablieren, das müssen wir uns patentieren
lassen erst mal, diagonale skalieren und dann müssen wir das irgendwie mal ManagerSpeak
unterbringen und dann müssen sie alle an uns hier, da müssen alle, da müssen alle
in Zukunft, die das verwenden an den Chatgebühren bezahlen.
Wir hatten mal ein Repo, unser allererstes, das was ich erzählt habe, unser allererstes
Automatisierungs, Server-Automatisierungs-Repo mit Puppet-Code drin, da haben wir den Fehler
gemacht, wir haben ein paar Java-Updates eingecheckt damals und ihr wisst, wie das ist mit der
Git-Historie und wer es nicht weiß, dem sage ich es jetzt, aus der Git-Historie, du bekommst
nie wieder was raus, einmal committed und gepusht, immer da, ich weiß, dass es Ausnahmen gibt,
aber die sind in der Regel nicht wirklich praktikabel, du kannst eine komplette Historie
umschreiben, dann ist es aber eine andere Historie, also einmal committed und gepusht
immer für immer im Repo drin und da, also wir hatten, wir hatten Java-Updates gepusht
und irgendwann war unser Git-Repo glaube, mehrere Gigabyte groß, also nicht so fett
wie das hier, mehr Gigabyte groß, es hat teilweise ewig gedauert zum klonen, das war richtig,
kennst du ein gutes Hobby als Ausgleich zum Beruf, also man kann es nicht Hobby nennen,
aber wie gesagt, ich gehe gerne wandern, nicht irgendwie 5-6 Stunden, sondern so 1,5-2 Stunden
am Tag ist gut, wenn man in der Gegend ein bisschen was, der Berge ist zu viel, ein bisschen
was Hügeliges hat, weil ich finde einfach nur geradeaus am Main laufen ist ziemlich
langweilig, aber wenn man zum Beispiel, es gibt zum Beispiel eine Strecke, die laufe
ich bei uns in der Ecke ganz gerne Maps, zeig mal Google Maps, Google Earth, konnte man
Google Earth nicht irgendwie tippen, Google Earth, wie viele Schritte, ich kann gleich
mal gucken, das muss ich glaube ich hier aufmachen, weil das sonst nicht richtig funktioniert
in Chrome, es gibt bei uns einen Berg, der ist glaube ich 480 Meter oder so hoch, das
ist für unsere Verhältnisse hier schon relativ hoch und hier laufe ich beispielsweise ganz
gern, ja guck, das ist so ein ganz kleines, so ein ganz kleines Kaff, da kann man von
hier unten, von hier unten kann man loslaufen, nicht liegt, da gehe ich manchmal wandern,
dass ich mich da treffe ist glaube ich relativ unwahrscheinlich, ja, ich wohne ja hier hinten,
ich wohne hier hinten in Hanau, so und es ist nicht weit weg, also es ist eh super hier
unten in, bei uns in der Ecke, ja das ist nicht weit weg, da fährst du 20 Minuten mit
dem Auto bis du da, ein bisschen länger kann man in Taunus fahren, aber das ist schon ein
bisschen, das ist ein ganzes Stück weiter weg, aber hier unten kann man wirklich wunderbar
wandern und wo ich wirklich gerne lang gehe ist hier, das dauert so ungefähr 2 Stunden
die Runde, dann läuft man von hier, ich versuche mal irgendwie da rein zu zoomen ob das gescheit
funktioniert, da läuft man von hier unten los, dann läuft man von hier unten los, geht
dann hier berghoch, man kann über den See laufen, dann geht man hier rauf, geht hier
außen rum, geht dann, eh, das stimmt nicht, man geht eigentlich hier durch und kommt dann
hier neben runter, ja hier sieht man den Weg noch ein bisschen, ja man läuft dann hier
oben rüber wieder zurück, ja und sowas ist halt zum Laufen tatsächlich recht angenehm,
das ist direkt an der Grenze zu Bayern, das ist direkt an der Grenze zu Bayern, hier ist
die bayerische Grenze, also hier ist Bayern, da ist Hessen, habe ich da gerade Groß-Kotzenburg
gelesen, ja Groß-Kotzenburg ist da hinten irgendwo, hier so, irgendwo, da, ja und sowas
finde ich halt wirklich angenehm zu laufen, weil es halt nicht einfach nur geradeaus ist,
ja bei uns könnte ich gerade außen am Main laufen, das ist langweilig, aber so ist super,
ja, da hast du dann so 300 Höhenmeter oder so, das ist nett zu laufen, bist ungefähr
zwei Stunden beschäftigt und finde ich ist ein super Ausgleich zu vorm Rechner sitzen.
Hörst du Musik oder Podcasts oder irgendwas, teilweise, teilweise Podcasts höre ich keine,
ich höre teilweise Musik, manchmal höre ich auch irgendwelche, entweder irgendwelche
YouTube Sachen oder irgendwelche Hörbücher oder sowas, aber das ist eigentlich relativ,
relativ selten, meistens, meistens habe ich eigentlich gar nichts auf dem Ohr, ja manchmal
habe ich ein bisschen Musik, aber ehrlich gesagt, ganz im Ernst, das ist ja, also ich
meine ihr müsst mal gucken, das ist wirklich am Arsch der Welt, das ist, also das ist ja
wirklich komplett Google Earth, ja hallo, das ist kaputt, ich meine guckt mal Leute,
das ist, das ist mega am Arsch der Welt, da ist nichts, hier guckt mal, da ist nichts,
hier sind, hier sind ein paar, hier sind ein paar Häuser, hier ist wirklich nichts und
dieses Dorf besteht zu, zu, keine Ahnung, 70% aus neuen Häusern, hier ist wirklich
gar nichts, so, pass mal auf mein, Emsbach, Mönbrys, Einwohnerzahl, Einwohner, Einwohner,
276 Leute, 276 Einwohner, da ist nichts Leute, du, du, du läufst, du läufst da selten
jemand über den Weg und du hörst da auch nichts, du hörst keine Autos, du hörst
ab und zu mal irgendwie einer, der mit dem Flugzeug rumfliegt, aber da ist nichts, das
ist tatsächlich, ich sage euch, ich sage euch wie es ist, es ist tatsächlich ganz angenehm,
nebenan vor dem Rechner zu sitzen und Kopfhörer den ganzen Tag aufzuhaben, einfach nix, nix
zu hören auf dem Ohr, ne, mach ich nicht, ich trinke, das ist das, das eine Sache,
das ich glücklicherweise noch nie oft gemacht hab und ich war trotzdem ziemlich pepo fett,
ich trinke nur Cola und Fanta und so hab ich nie getrunken, das einzige, wo ich Cola und
Fanta getrunken hab, ist halt, wenn ich zum Mittagessen in Frankfurt gegangen bin, weil
da hattest du die Auswahl, 0,5er Cola für irgendwie ein paar Euro oder ne Flasche Wasser
für 7 Euro oder so, oder so 0,2er Wasser, wo du einmal dran nippst und es ist weg, ich
hatte übrigens letztens die feifhänigste Geldsparidee aller Zeiten, aber ich glaube,
das ist eigentlich schon fast assi, ich hab überlegt, man kann Mittagessen gehen und
es, man geht dann einfach aufs Klo was trinken am Wasserhahn, nimmt sich irgendwie ein Becher
mit und dann geht man wieder essen und dann geht man nochmal, wenn man fertig essen ist
aufs Klo, nimmt sich irgendwie ein Becher mit und trinkt dann, trinkt einfach aus dem
Wasserhahn Wasser und dann kann man sich 5 Euro sparen, aber ich glaube, das ist ja
für die Leben nicht so gut, weil die verdienen ziemlich viel Geld rein an Getränken, aber
mittlerweile ist alles so teuer, muss man halt auch zu sowas greifen. Wie ich das gemacht
hab, wie gesagt, ich mach eigentlich nix außer mich mehr bewegen, ich bewege mich jeden
Tag eineinhalb, zwei Stunden, außer manchmal sonntags, kaltes Leitungswasser müssen sie
dir kostenfrei anbieten, nur müssen sie in Deutschland gar nicht, ich mein die müssen
dir Wasser aufm Klo zum Händewaschen anbieten, aber nicht als Trinken. In Frankreich ist
das glaube ich anders, in Deutschland müssen die das nicht. Achja, ich wollte nachschauen
wieviel Schritte, ok, Moment, ich gucke, ich gucke, ich gucke Leute, äh, Health, sieht
man da glaube ich hier, oder? Also Total Steps, Total Steps sind es heute 13.606. Und wieviele
Kilometer da sind, weiß ich nicht, das steht da nicht. Kilometer steht da nicht dabei.
Ja, ungefähr eineinhalb bis zwei Stunden. Äh, gar nicht so oft, ich war da jetzt schon
bestimmt drei Monate oder so nicht mehr. Das heißt, die hat jetzt quasi die gesammelte
Menge aus irgendwie, keine Ahnung, nochmal acht Kilo abgenommen auf einmal gesehen. Aber
das ist ja aufgefallen. Ja, das stimmt, wobei man sagen muss, dass es einem besser geht
also wenn man das eine Weile gemacht hat, geht es einem besser, also wenn es einem schlecht
geht und man kann das dann machen, geht es einem wieder besser. Es ist eigentlich eher,
es ist eher, dass es einem, es trägt eher dazu bei, dass es einem wieder besser geht,
wenn man so regelmäßige Sachen weitermachen kann. Hä, was? Achso, da ging es um, um die
Geschichte mit, dass was, dass man, dass der Arbeitgeber vorsorgen muss oder so, was ich
erzählt habe, ja.
Das stimmt wohl, wobei ich auch sagen muss, ich lerne am liebsten für mich neue Sachen
und gerade hier auch im Stream, ich habe schon so viel hier mit dem Stream zusammen gelernt,
was mir dann entweder mal was gebracht hat auf der Arbeit oder auch nicht, aber generell
so Knowledge, so breite, breite, breite Ahnung von verschiedenen Themen bringt eigentlich
immer was. Du warst gestern krank, 40,7 Fieber, oh, auch das Virus, ja. Hast du eine Smartwatch?
Nein, habe ich nicht. Ich habe mein Handy aber immer dabei. Vielleicht würde eine Smartwatch
das ganze noch besser zählen kann sein. Müssen wir mal gucken, ob meine Wanda-App sinnvolle
Smartwatch Integration hat, die irgendwas bringt. Keine Ahnung. Madding Gamer, Dankeschön
für den Zap. Ja, wie gesagt, also ich gehe keine 4, 5, 6 Stunden wandern oder so. Dafür
mache ich es halt jeden Tag. Das ist eine blöde Idee, die Datenbank zu committen. Hier,
Serious Maxis, wo du sagst, ich höre tatsächlich manchmal, wenn ich rumlaufe, ein bisschen
ASMR Videos. Normalerweise sollte man ja eigentlich beim Sport machen, irgendwelche Musik hören,
die dich so aufpumpt oder so, keine Ahnung. Ich laufe eh zum Entspannen rum, ich höre
tatsächlich manchmal ein bisschen ASMR Videos. Aber ich höre keine, was gibt es da so, keine
Katzen, Rollplay, leck dir die Ohren, ASMR Videos oder so. Das ist denn nicht meins.
Das ist eine gute Idee. Fällt mir auch was ein. Azubi, ehemaliger Azubi, kann es eigentlich
gar keinem erzählen. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das erzähle. Wobei, der ist nicht mehr
bei uns, kann ich erzählen. Kann ich erzählen, der ist nicht mehr bei uns. Der wollte mal
beweisen, was für ein toller Kerl er ist, dass er es schafft, ein Schnitzel an der Kasse
vorbei zu schmuggeln. Oder hat er sich einen Teller genommen, hat er eine Nudel drauf gemacht,
hat wirklich einen Teller, hat die Nudel bis zur Decke auf dem Teller gestapelt und hat
da halt einen Schnitzel drunter gelegt und hat dann bei der Kasse nur Nudeln abgerechnet
und wollte dann halt irgendwie zeigen, was für ein geiler Kerl er ist, dass er einen
Schnitzel rausgeschmuggelt hat, ohne zu bezahlen aus der Kantine. Als wäre er so arm, dass
er die 250 oder so für der Schnitzel nicht mehr hätte. Nice. Aber 30 Kilo ist heftig,
also ich meine, ich habe ungefähr seit April jetzt 15 Kilo und ich habe schon ein bisschen
Löcherimpe auch hier. Na ja, das ist übertrieben gesagt, aber man sieht halt manchmal da, wo
Speck war und jetzt kein Speck mehr ist. Ich kann gar nicht vorstellen, wie das mit 30
Kilo ist. Ja, Prezary, warst du bei dir auch das Virus? Hast du einen Test gemacht? Weißt
du schon? Ja, das finde ich nice. Habe ich jetzt schon öfters gelesen im Chat, dass
Leute gesagt haben, guck mal, habe ich wieder was gelernt? Ich versuche ja auch immer so
nebenbei, wenn mir gerade was einfällt, immer noch so ein bisschen was zu erzählen, zum
Beispiel letztens das über Suchmaschinen, wie das funktioniert mit so einem Inverted
Index und sowas. Ich versuche ja immer mal zwischendurch ein bisschen, ein bisschen
Pfeiffer Themen reinzubringen, auch in Streams, wo es eigentlich nicht Hauptthema ist, irgendwas
spezielles zu machen. Manchmal muss das sein. Ich finde das übrigens schön, wenn ihr das
schreibt, sowas, das motiviert mich, wenn ich sehe, dass die Leute was lernen. Und ihr
glaubt es nicht, ich habe auch schon einiges gelernt, rein weil wir uns das im Stream angeguckt
haben. Nächstes Wochenende gibt es wahrscheinlich
Hetzner Sponsored Stream. Ich musste das jetzt leider ein bisschen aufschieben, wegen dem
Virus, das mich befallen hat die letzten zwei Wochen. Und deswegen muss ich das verschieben.
Wahrscheinlich nächstes Wochenende. Da schauen wir uns nochmal im Detail an, das neue Hetzner
Feature, dass man jetzt flexible IP-Adressen haben kann, also sprich Server nur mit internen
IP, Server mit externen IP, sowohl IPv4 als auch IPv6. Und ich zeige euch ein Setup, wie
man das sinnvoll benutzen kann. Also zum Beispiel mit einem Eingangsserver und dann drei internen
System, die nicht aus dem Internet erreichbar sind, und wie man das konfigurieren kann.
Das machen wir beim nächsten Wochenende. Ey Leute, ihr könnt es mir glauben oder nicht,
ist mir eigentlich relativ egal, ist nichts Verwerfliches daran, sowas zu hören, aber
mein Fall ist es nicht. Also wenn wir es jetzt gerade schon von solchen Videos haben. Also
es gibt einen ASMR Channel, den höre ich wirklich gerne, einfach weil es äußerst kreativer
Content ist, allerdings auch nicht alles. Und das ist, wie heißt er, so heißt er, schreibt
man ihn glaube ich, ihn hier. Den gucke ich wirklich gern. Nicht unbedingt alles, da sind
teilweise sehr abgedrehte Sachen dabei, aber den finde ich zum größten Teil sehr kreative
Videos, die man auch gucken kann, ohne dabei zu schlafen. Doch bei uns waren immer irgendwelche
Aufpasserinnen, eigentlich waren es nur Aufpasserinnen, die an der Kasse aufgepasst haben, dass keiner
was vorbeischmuggelt. Ist gerade Abnehmzeit hier, der Stream. Chat, bald alles Giga-Chat
hier, der Chat, wenn es so weiter geht. Sixpack-Chat. Das ist doch nice. Na geil. Ja, du kannst
ja, stimmt, das vergisst man in aktuellen Zeiten schnell, es gibt ja noch viel mehr
andere Sachen außer Corona, die man sich einfangen kann. Gibt ja auch noch normale
Grippe und alles mögliche, wo man auch mal höher Fieber haben kann. Also ich muss sagen,
ganz ehrlich, die Corona-Geschichte an sich, die waren drei, dreieinhalb Tage richtig beschissen.
Also mir ging es wirklich schlecht, was Erkältungssymptome angeht. Also sowohl von Kopfschmerzen bis
Husten bis Nasenlaufen, Halsschmerzen, Fieber, ich glaube das höchste war, ich hatte 9,32
oder so. Also mir ging es drei Tage, dreieinhalb Tage wirklich kacke. Aber danach ging es auch
relativ schnell wieder aufwärts. Das Einzige, was wirklich, was mir lange zu schaffen gemacht
hat oder was mir am meisten zu schaffen gemacht hat, ist, dass da noch so Sachen dabei gekommen
sind, wie, dass man anders schmeckt und anders riecht. Das ist ganz merkwürdig, das kann
man gar nicht richtig erklären. Normalerweise denkt ihr euch nichts dran, ja, da liegt ihr
bei euch im Schlafzimmer in der Wohnung und ja, es riecht eigentlich nach nichts, sofern
ihr ab und zu mal lüftet und sauber macht. Aber eigentlich riecht das nach nichts, ihr
denkt euch nichts dabei. Wenn ihr aber Corona habt und auf einmal nichts mehr oder irgendwie
die Sachen anders schmeckt und anders riecht, dann riecht eure Wohnung anders und das ist
so, das ist so subtil im Hintergrund immer, dass es euch sogar ein bisschen schlecht davon
wird. Zumindest hatte ich das, weil ich die ganze Zeit gerade habe, aber irgendwas, was
ist denn hier, ist doch komisch, irgendwas stimmt nicht. Also das ist das, was mich am
meisten verwirrt hat bei der ganzen Sache. Ansonsten, was halt bei Corona wirklich ätzend
war, dass du so richtig im Arsch bist. Normalerweise ist Erkältung ist vorbei, die hält länger,
ja, also da bist du mit dreieinhalb, vier Tagen nicht, Symptomen nicht durch, das hält
ja meistens mal mindestens eine Woche, aber du bist nach Corona richtig schlapp. Also
sowohl im Kopf als auch so körperlich. Also ich konnte die ersten Tage nicht großartig
rumlaufen draußen oder geschweige denn meine eineinhalb Stunden, zwei Stunden Runden da
am Tag machen, das konntest du knicken. Ich hatte zusätzlich hatte ich noch, ich hatte
so ganz komische Sachen bei Corona noch. Ich hatte einen Ruhepuls von irgendwie 91 oder
so, normalerweise habe ich 72 oder so. Und dementsprechend konnte ich gar nicht richtig
schlafen, weil versucht man mit einem Puls von 91 zu schlafen, das ist gar nicht so einfach.
Ich habe immer gelegen, war eigentlich müde, aber konnte nicht schlafen, weil ich halt
so einen hohen Puls hatte und ich bin dann, ohne Mist, ich bin glaube ich 70% der Zeit
rumgelaufen, sowohl tagsüber als auch nachts. Ich bin einfach rumgelaufen, ums Bett, bei
mir in der Wohnung, vom Wohnzimmer ins Arbeitszimmer ins Bad, habe was getrunken, bin rumgelaufen,
ich bin 70%, auch nachts, ich bin rumgelaufen, weil ich habe einfach keine Ruhe gefunden
und keine Erholung irgendwie, weil ich halt so einen hohen Puls hatte und krank war und
das war ganz ganz komisch, das hatte ich noch nie so was. Hatte ich auch ein bisschen Bedenken,
ich habe sogar bei dieser Corona Hotline angerufen, deswegen, mal abends, ich hatte irgendwann
so, keine Ahnung, so 23 Uhr oder so, hatte ich wirklich so ein bisschen Panik, weil man
war auf der einen Seite komplett im Arsch und schlapp, aber trotzdem keine Ruhe gefunden
und sowas. Da habe ich da angerufen und da muss ich sagen, die waren wirklich hilfreich,
die haben mich beruhigt und haben halt erklärt, das ist normal, das haben ganz viele, muss
ich mir keine Gedanken machen und 91 ist überhaupt kein Problem. Ja, klar, da findet man keine
Ruhe, aber muss man sich überhaupt keine Gedanken machen. Ich habe ja dann auch keinen
Hunger gehabt, so richtig, ich habe auch nichts richtig gegessen, zwei Tage lang, einfach
weil man riecht nichts und man ist eh kaputt und man hat keinen Hunger. Ich habe dann zwei
Tage nichts gegessen, dementsprechend war ich noch mehr kaputt als davor und ich konnte
halt die ganze Zeit nicht pennen, weil ich irgendwie so einen Puls von 95 hatte und nicht
zur Ruhe gekommen bin. Also das war wirklich eine richtig kacke Kombination, muss ich sagen,
aber irgendwann dann so am, ja so am, weiß ich, am vierten Tag oder so, würde ich sagen,
hatte ich abends auf einmal Hunger und ich habe, ich hatte noch aus dem Lidl sowas hier
und ich habe so ein halbes Ding gefressen abends oder eher dreiviertel Ding. Ich bin
abends in die Küche, habe gedacht Max, du hast Hunger und ich habe einfach so ein dreiviertel
Ding gefressen davon und danach ging es mir besser und ab dann ging es aufwärts. Irgendwie
hatte ich, wissen wir, mir ging es richtig scheiße den ganzen Tag und abends habe ich
so gedacht, Max, jetzt hast du Hunger. Küche, dreiviertel Hefezopf reingedrückt und danach
ist es gut. Danach ging es mir wieder besser. 500.000 Kanalpunkte, krass. Man kann damit
immer noch nichts machen. Ein Jump-Post bauen, auch, sowas werden wir auch machen, aber viel
interessanter ist, wie bringt man seine internen Server ins Internet, dass die Updates ziehen
können und sowas. Den kenne ich nicht. Pass mal auf, wenn ich jetzt danach suche, gibt
es, oh nee, das ist bestimmt irgendwelche, das mache ich jetzt nicht auf, Chat, das ist
auch bestimmt irgendwelche Ear-Licking-Geschichten oder so wieder, ASMR-Videos. Ich gucke kaum
Mädels, muss ich sagen, was ASMR-Channels angeht. Ja, das ist normal, aber trotzdem,
versuch mal zu schlafen oder versuch dich mal zu entspannen mit einem Puls von zwischen
91 und 95. Das ist normalerweise das, was du so hast, wenn du ein bisschen rumläufst
und dementsprechend ging es mir auch besser. Ich bin 70% der Zeit rumgelaufen, auch nachts
und das ging dann sogar so weit, dass mir irgendwann meine Waden wehgetan haben, weil
ich habe halt nichts gegessen und bin den ganzen Tag rumgelaufen, auch nachts und dann
hat irgendwann angefangen mir noch die Waden weh zu tun während Corona. Also ich kann euch
ehrlich, ich kann euch nur sagen, also den Scheiß will man nicht haben. Also es war
wirklich, war nicht so toll. Jetzt habe ich übrigens noch weniger Bock auf die Arbeit
zu fahren nach Frankfurt, um mit dem Scheiß vielleicht noch mal einzufangen. Achso. Wenn
es danach geht, gibt es immer Schlimmeres. Dir könnte jetzt auch die Flugzeugturbine
auf den Kopf fallen, wenn du vor die Tür gehst. Also ich glaube, das ist nicht der
Maßstab der Dinge, dass man sagt, es gibt noch Schlimmeres. Also es gibt Sachen, die
sind scheiße, ja es gibt aber Sachen, die sind noch beschissener, das machen aber Sachen,
die scheiße sind nicht automatisch besser. Das ist wie wenn ich sage, ja also irgendwie,
was weiß ich, ich bin mit irgendwas nicht zufrieden und irgendjemand sagt dann, ja es
gibt doch Leute, denen geht es noch schlechter oder so. Ja natürlich gibt es Schlimmeres,
aber es war wirklich nichts tolles. Also es ist nichts, was man haben will. Es ist beschissener
gewesen, als ich es mir vorgestellt habe. Ja genau. Jetzt machen wir euch die GitHub
Trends. Da gucken wir jetzt schnell nochmal rein. Shithub. Was trennt ihr denn auf Shithub?
Was ist denn da los? Leute ist Shithub down? Kann das sein? Ist Shithub? Shithub ist down.
Gibt es da nicht irgendwie so eine down-Seite, down-Status? Naja, ne nicht wirklich. Also
mein GitHub tut es gerade nicht. Ist wieder da, ok. Also bei mir geht GitHub gerade nicht
so, wie es aussieht. Achja, da sind wir wieder. Also Explore Trending, zeigt mal her. Was
trendet denn? Today. New Pipe. Tja, wenn es sowas für IOS gäbe, wäre cool. Shadowsocks.
Rock. Eine neue Sprache in Rust. Ok, das ist für die coolen Leute, die sagen können,
Written in Rust. Ok, solange es kein Hello World Beispiel gibt, gucke ich mir das nicht
an. Top Software, benutze ich auch. Auch gut. Naja, schockt mich jetzt nicht so, was da
gerade trendet. Wann geht es weiter? Wir brauchen erstmal einen ordentlichen Anwendungszweck.
Was wir da noch machen wollen. Tja. Schauen wir mal. Komm, wir gucken uns jetzt noch ein
paar Videos an auf YouTube. Ich habe jetzt eineinhalb Stunden gelabert, ich merke schon
wieder im Hals. Das hat der Chat gepostet vorhin. Weiß ich, ob ich das angucken soll.
Guck mal, meine eigenen Videos. So muss das sein. Aber 25 Minuten ist mir eigentlich zu
lang. Das will ich jetzt auch nicht gucken. Weep-Hintergrund. Was haben wir hier sonst
noch? Wir lassen uns Level-Captchi baiten. Level-Captchi bait. Wir lassen uns Level-Captchi
baiten. Einfach einmal gucken. Wobei eigentlich ist da glaube ich gar nichts drin, was mich
interessiert. Star Citizen juckt mich nicht. XP-Bug juckt mich auch nicht. Cancelled Campaign
Black Ops 4 juckt mich auch nicht. Ja, was die da sichtbar wieder in den Kopf schmeißen,
das ist auch egal. Apex Neue Season juckt mich auch nicht. Tarkov juckt mich auch nicht.
Half-Life VR Mod. Ja, gut, wenn ich eine VR-Brille hätte. Okay, wir müssen uns jetzt gucken,
da ist nichts dabei, was mich interessiert. Keg-Waite. Was ist das? Die Angst vor neuen
Medien. Okay, zeig her. Das haben eigentlich nur Boomer. Also so Leute wie ich. Mir ist
übrigens was eingefallen. Vorhin ist mir was eingefallen. Leute, ich will keinen traurig
machen oder so. Er hat auch nichts mit Fields Batman zu tun. Mir ist bloß eine Sache vorhin
eingefallen. Und zwar, mein Opa ist ja gestorben vor, der wäre jetzt 90 glaube ich. Nee,
nee, nee. Ist auch egal. Ist schon ein paar Jahre her. Ich habe doch mit meinem Opa sogar
ein Video gemacht. Hier, 2012 ist er gestorben. Und mir ist aufgefallen, leider, der hat ja
gerne Bilder gemalt. Gibt es ja noch Max FPS, Dach, gibt es ja sogar noch Bilder von. Ach
nee, das Video habe ich glaube ich gelöscht. Also hat er gerne gemalt. Der hat ja gerne
gemalt und mir ist aufgefallen, was für eine richtig coole Erfindung gewesen wäre, wäre
ein iPad mit den ganzen aktuellen Tools, die es da drauf gibt. Also von den ganzen Sketch
Software und mit den Stiften. Weil der war ja nicht sonderlich scharf auf Technik mein
Opa, muss man sagen. Sein Lieblingsspruch war, wenn ich ihm irgendwas geschenkt habe,
was mit Technik zu tun hat, sei es jetzt ein DVD-Player oder ich habe ihm beispielsweise
auch mal, weil er nachts immer nicht wusste, wieviel Uhr es ist und ein Wecker geschenkt,
der die Uhrzeit und die Decke projiziert und so was. Der hat immer gesagt, oh, das ist
ja cool, ach das ist für mich, ach ich brauch das doch gar nicht, sei es so gut, nimmst
doch wieder mit, du brauchst es doch viel mehr als ich und so. Der wollte neue Sachen
nicht, also der hatte wirklich Abneigung gegen neue Sachen. Aber ich glaube, ein iPad mit
dem passenden Stift zum Malen, so zum Zeichnen, hätte meinem Opa wirklich gut gefallen.
Der hätte erstmal gesagt, ah so ein Scheiß, das brauche ich nicht, da halte ich nichts
von und so, dann hätte ich es mal mit dem zusammen ausprobieren müssen und dann hätte
der mit der Zeit wahrscheinlich gemerkt, das ist gar nicht schlecht. Aber das hat er leider
nicht mehr erlebt, das hätte ihm bestimmt gefallen. So, also Angst vor Medium. Auf geht's.
Vor einigen hunderten Jahren, als der Buchdruck erfunden war und der Roman als neues Massenmedium
einzukehlt, fingen die Leute an sich reihenweise über die in vielen G-
Ja das ist ja normal, über Killerspiele haben sie sich ja auch aufgeregt, ich weiß nicht,
was Christian Pfeiffer aktuell so macht, aber das war ja immer bei neuen Sachen so, ja,
Video verdirbt die Jugend, Buchdruck verdirbt die Jugend, Killerspiele verdirbt die Jugend,
TikTok verdirbt die Jugend, wobei ich sagen muss, ganz ehrlich, von allem ist wahrscheinlich
TikTok noch die gefährlichste Sache davon, die problematischste Sache davon, ja, aber
ich mein TikTok sieht man mal wieder eine Sache richtig gut dran. Die Plattform ist
nicht so wirklich, ist nicht so wirklich das, was die Probleme macht, sondern halt die Dummheit
der Leute und das war es im Prinzip schon immer, dass die Dummheit der Leute das eigentliche
Problem ist. Ich mein, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das mitbekommen habt, von einem Jungen
aus England, der im Koma lag, wo dann die Eltern, etwas weniger Z-Gekram im Hintergrund
jetzt ja, wo dann die Eltern geklagt haben, dass die Beatmung abgestellt, dass die Beatmung
nicht abgestellt wird und sowas, vielleicht habt ihr das mitgekriegt, das war vor ein
paar Tagen, war das so in den Medien, in den News, ja, und wisst ihr, warum der Junge
im Koma lag? Das habe ich nämlich auch erst im Nachhinein durch den Newsartikel rausgekriegt,
durch eine TikTok-Challenge, der war glaube ich zwölf, fünfzehn oder zwölf, ich glaube
zwölf, und der hat bei einer TikTok-Challenge mitgemacht, und zwar bei einer, frag mich
nicht, wie das heißt, so einer, ich erwürge mich selbst TikTok-Challenge, und dann frage
ich mich so allen Ernstes, Leute, also, ja, auf TikTok wird viel Scheiße gelabert und
Scheiße gemacht, aber, dass eine, ich erwürge mich selbst-Challenge nicht gut ist, für
die eigene Gesundheit, auf die Idee muss doch noch wirklich der, der kleinste, das
kleinste IQ-Hirn kommen. Ja, das ist, das ist die nächste Steigerung von Wäsche-Pots-Essen,
wobei ich sagen muss, bei uns, also, wo ich jünger war, wurde auch viel Scheiße gemacht,
ja, damals war ja das große Thema Koma-Saufen angesagt, wo damals die älteren Leute gesagt
haben, so nach dem Motto, unsere Jugend, die verrecken alle, und ja, das war sicherlich
auch problematisch, und die Leute haben dort auch wirklich dummes Zeug gemacht, die haben
sich beispielsweise damals Tampons, Tampons in, kein Spaß, ich denk mir das nicht aus,
muss ich aber so klar sagen, aber das war wirklich ein Problem damals, die haben Tampons
genommen und haben das in Wodka getunkt, und haben sich die Tampons dann entweder als Zäppchen
in Poppers geschoben, oder halt, naja, wo man sich Tampons halt sonst so hinschiebt,
und das hat dann dazu geführt, dass du über die Schleimhäute dieses ganze Zeug ungefiltert
aufgenommen hast, und die Leute reinweise ins Krankenhaus gekommen sind mit Alkoholvergiftung,
also, die haben damals, als ich jung war, auch richtig dummes Zeug gemacht, aber, ganz
im Ernst, ich finde, der Zusammenhang zwischen, ich steck mir was mit Wodka in den Poppers
und komm dann ins Krankenhaus, der ist schon sehr offensichtlich, trotzdem haben es die
Schleimhäute gemacht, aber, der Zusammenhang zwischen, ich binde mir was um den Hals und
erwürge mich, der ist noch klarer, oder, also ich mein, man muss nicht der Hellste sein,
man muss nicht weit denken können, um auf die Idee zu kommen, dass ein Wodka getränkt
des Tampons sich in Poppers zu schieben, keine gute Idee ist, aber ich glaube, man muss noch
weniger weit denken, um auf die Idee zu kommen, dass sich erwürgen noch instant schlechter
auf einen auswirkt, ja, zumindest der Junge hat bei irgendeiner, äh, ich erwürge mich
TikTok-Challenge mitgemacht, hat sich irgendwas um den Hals gebunden und hat sich da wahrscheinlich
im Smartphone auch noch gefilmt oder so, ähm, hat bei der TikTok-Challenge mitgemacht,
gut, hat sich halt erwürgt, die Mutter hat ihn gefunden, gewisse Zeit später und halt
komplett Hirn im Arsch, lag dann jetzt halt im Koma im Krankenhaus und es ist halt einfach,
wie kann man so dumm sein, und ich bin mir da halt nicht sicher, inwieweit man das überhaupt
TikTok wirklich anlasten kann, ich mein, es ist halt die Plattform, die junge Leute verwenden,
aber ich mein, TikTok kann doch nichts dafür, dass die Leute einfach unglaublich dumm sind,
da kann nur TikTok nichts für, ich weiß nicht, ob TikTok gegen solche Challenges vorgeht,
dass solche Videos quasi, äh, geflaggt werden, weil, sag mal mal so, wenn es keine Zuschauer
bekommt, dann gucken es wahrscheinlich auch weniger und machen auch weniger, aber, also
so dumm kann man doch eigentlich gar nicht sein, es muss doch jedem klar sein, wenn ich
mir was um den Hals binde und mich erwürge, dass das nicht gut ist für mich, das ist,
selbst Wäschetaps essen ist noch eine Nummer weniger direkt, Wäschetaps essen, da stirbst
du nicht instant von, aber von ich erwürge mich, stirbst du instant, also der Zusammenhang
zwischen ich binde mir was um den Hals und erwürge mich und ich kann davon sterben,
der ist einfach, den kannst du doch gar nicht übersehen, naja gut, also, also bei TikTok,
TikTok ist glaube ich wirklich das gefährlichste von allen, diese ganzen Krämpfe, oh man,
also ich verstehe, manchmal weiß ich echt nicht, wie man so bescheuert sein kann, heutzutage,
es ist ja nicht mal heutzutage, es stimmt ja gar nicht, Leute in meinem Alter als jung
mal hätten jetzt gleiche gemacht, wie gesagt, viel schlauer sich ein Wodka getränktes Tampon
in Poppes zu schieben ist es auch nicht, die Leute sind einfach dumm und das ist das hauptsächliche
Problem und war es auch schon immer, ich würde gar nicht sagen, dass die Leute noch dümmer
werden, ich glaube die Dummheit wird einfach nur immer besser zur Schau gestellt mittlerweile,
ich glaube dumm waren die alle schon immer, so, gucken wir das Video.
Geschichten verwendete ich Perspektive zu empören, der Ich Erzähler würde, so der Vorwurf zu
einer Aufweichung der Grenzen zwischen dem Leser und den fiktiven Gedanken und Taten
der Romanfigur führen, man könnte ja gar nicht mehr wissen, was die eigenen und was
fremde Schlussfolgerungen wären und wenn die Gedanken fiktiver Krimineller mit den
eigenen verschmelzen, naja, das war doch schon immer so, dass bei neuer Technik beziehungsweise
neuen Medien von denen, von der Generation, die davor da war, der Weltuntergang irgendwie
prophezeit wurde, wir hatten schon so viele Sachen, wo angeblich die Jugend, ja, verroht
und verblödet und sonst was und letztendlich, es gibt uns immer noch und es gibt mehr Menschen
als je zuvor, also es scheint nicht funktioniert zu haben.
Schnell den Salat, diese Erzählung hatte auf mich und die Bildung meiner Perspektive
auf Medien und der gesellschaftlichen Beurteilung von ihnen einen großen Einfluss, in der Recherche
zu diesem Video musste ich allerdings herausfinden, dass es keinerlei Beweise für ihre Echtheit
gibt.
Dennoch, wenn man sich die Diskussion der letzten 20 Jahre zu Videospielen, ihrem vermeintlichen
Einfluss auf die Aggressivität von Kindern und der Reduzierung aller gesellschaftlichen
Probleme auf Instagram-Feeds mal so anschaut, fällt sie zumindest nicht aus dem Muster.
Was ist eigentlich aus Regine Pfeiffer geworden?
Das muss ich jetzt gerade mal kurz gucken.
Regine Pfeiffer.
Da ist sie doch.
Moment, die kann man auf Google bewir- Die ist doch nicht wirklich EDV-Berater, oder?
Das ist doch fake.
Olli, genau die verwende ich.
Welche benutzt du?
Muss nicht, Digga.
Oh, Mann.
Das hat meine Oma auch immer erzählt, viereckige Augen, ja, ist klar.
Weil die Leute Angst haben vor dem, was sie nicht kennen, ist doch bei allem so.
Ja, Olli, ich habe auch keine Smartwatch.
Das hier ist Arrival of a Train, ein 50-sekündiger Stummfilm aus dem Jahr 1895 und einer der
allerersten seiner Art.
Ein Zug fährt in einem französischen Bahnhof ein, ein Junge trägt einen absurdgroßen
Hut und nahezu jeder, der die Gelegenheit bekommt, schaut direkt in die Kamera.
Aber es hat funktioniert.
Völlig ohne Post-Credit-Szene und sogar so gut, dass die Leute bei der ersten öffentlichen
Vorstellung in Panik ausgebrochen sind, weil sie dachten, dass der Zug aus der Leinwand
herausfährt und das Publikum überrollt.
Da siehste, es war damals auch schon nicht so weit her mit Nachdenken bei den Leuten.
Das stimmt mit an Sicherheit grenzender Wahrscheinlichkeit nicht, aber das hat man sich damals so erzählt
und dieses Gerücht hält sich bis heute.
Und auch wenn damals niemand gefilmt hat, wie Leute darauf reagiert haben, dass jemand
einen Zug gefilmt hat.
Übrigens, wisst ihr was auch nicht stimmt?
Kennt ihr dieses Gerücht, dass der Mensch im Jahr 8 Spinnen im Schlaf ist im Durchschnitt?
Habt ihr bestimmt auch schon mal gehört, oder?
Das ist auch kompletter Blödsinn.
Weißt, das hält sich aber auch.
Leute, Leute, Sendung mit der Maus versus Sesamstraße, wie ist das bei euch?
Das ist recht, ja.
Beides lost.
Ich weiß nicht, ich mochte die Sendung mit der Maus mehr.
Die gab's auch, ja.
Die waren aber erst danach.
Ich fand die Sendung mit der Maus auch besser.
Die amerikanischen Superhelden waren auch nicht weit, denn schließlich würden die
ja in ihren Comics stets antidemokratische Lösungswege heroisieren.
Wer seinen Kindern also einen Comic von der Tanke mitbringt, der hat nicht nur sein Kind
falsch erzogen, der hat auch gleich mal das politische Fundament des ganzen Landes vermint.
Gut, das kriegst du heute auf Twitter aber auch an jeder Ecke erzählt.
Ja, Heavy Metal ist ja auch ganz böse der Teufel.
Number of the Beast, Alter, ist vorbei.
Ja, Hallo Spencer kenn ich noch, das war auch nicht schlecht.
Und als Romane langsam der letzte Schrei wurden, ließ auch die Angst vor ihn nicht lange
auf sich warten, deswegen sagt man auch heute noch, Lesen verdirbt den Charakter und schadet
dem Körper.
So, aber gerade die gesellschaftliche Rehabilitierung des Romans, des Buches allgemein, scheint
ja zu zeigen, dass das eine Haltung ist, aus der die Gesellschaft irgendwann rauswächst.
Schließlich würde sich ja heute kein Elternteil Sorgen machen, wenn das Kind zwei Stunden
am Tag liest, statt am Computer zu stehen, und der Blick in eine U-Bahn oder ein Bus,
in dem jeder Passagier in sich gekehrt auf sein Handy schaut, ist unendlich deprimierend,
aber wenn alle stattdessen eine Zeitung aus Papier lesen würden ja...
Wie ist das?
Ohne Scheiß, ich kenn die Zeitung mit den Zeitungslesern noch.
Ich sag euch jetzt mal, wie ich das sehe, die Zeiten heute sind mir um ein Vielfaches
lieber als die Zeitungleser.
Weiß nicht, ob sich einer noch an die Zeiten erinnert, wo alle Leute wie wild Zeitungen
geplattert haben morgens im Zug und sich ausgebreitet haben über vier Sitze mit ihrer
Scheißzeitung.
Das ist mit dem Handy viel besser.
Dann ist ja alles in Ordnung.
Scheinbar irrationale Reaktionen von Menschen auf einen Umstand haben...
Ja David, das verstehe ich auch nicht, warum sich das hält.
Das ist aber nur in Deutschland so.
Ich hab jetzt von einigen, also international denkt das Park Rammstein niemand, aber in
Deutschland hab ich schon irgendwie öfters gehört so nach dem Motto, Rammstein, ho, haben
die nicht, haben die nicht irgendwas mit Rechten zu tun oder so?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie man auf die Idee kommt.
Also weder von den Textern, ja, es ist härtere Musik und ich muss sagen mir gefällt persönlich
Rammstein noch nicht mal sonderlich gut, aber keine Ahnung, also wie man auf die Idee kommen
kann ist mir schleierhaft.
Das denken auch wirklich nur ein paar Leute hier anscheinend.
Ich immer dieselbe Ursache, die Angst vor Kontroll oder eher Machtverlust.
Als die katholische Kirche kurz nach der Erfindung des Buchdrucks diesen als unchristlich und
Teufelswerk bezeichnete, war das überraschenderweise keine fundierte Kritik an einer neuen Technologie.
Es war die Angst davor, dass bald jeder nachprüfen konnte, was der Priester im Gottesdienst
so für Weisheiten rausballert.
Das Ganze ist in dieser Sache sehr eng mit Nostalgie verknüpft.
Auch wenn wir uns da gerne als Ausnahme verstehen, unser Gehirn merkt sich nicht alles aus einer
Zeit, sondern es filtert.
Und für gewöhnlich haben dabei positive Erinnerungen eine höhere Wahrscheinlichkeit
erinnert zu werden als negative.
Außer, außer es sind sehr negative, weil in der Regel, also ich weiß gar nicht ob das
wirklich so ist, ich weiß gar nicht ob das wirklich so ist, weil es hat ja durchaus,
weil es hat ja durchaus seinen Vorteil, also sagen wir mal so, es hat theoretisch einen
größeren Mehrwert sich an negative Sachen zu erinnern als an positive Sachen.
Wenn man mal so auf Gefahrenvermeidung und sowas aus ist, ja, also zum Beispiel wenn
du über die Straße gehen willst und die Ampel ist rot und irgendein Typ kanns wieder
nicht abwarten und läuft über die Ampel und es kommt ein LKW um die Ecke gefahren
und zersplattert den Typ komplett.
Sich daran zu erinnern, wenn man das nächste Mal an der roten Ampel steht ist nicht schlecht,
weil man möchte ja nicht selbst der gesplatterte Typ sein.
Und generell so Sachen wo was in die Hose gegangen ist, sich daran zu erinnern so rein
aus für die Zukunft und bessere Entscheidungen zu treffen ist ja nicht verkehrt.
Wer will an seinem Lebensabend schon zurückschauen und sagen, ja das war gar nichts, ich hab
ja mal original überhaupt nichts auf die Reihe gekriegt.
Aus diesem Grund ist unsere Erinnerung meist positiver als die Realität und das trügt
uns, wenn wir sie mit der viel präsenteren Gegenwart vergleichen.
So haben wir das Gefühl, dass die Art, wie wir medial aufgewachsen sind, ideal war.
Ohne Smartphone, nur mit Kika, aber ohne jemals Super RTL aufrufen zu dürfen und vielleicht
an einem regnerischen Mittwoch mal eine halbe Stunde Wikipedia im Computer.
Ja, das ist die Art aufzuwachsen.
Alles andere ist reines Glücksspiel.
Jeder kennt eine solche Person, die ständig unaufgefordert betont, wie der vom Elternhaus
ausgerufene Verzicht von medialen Möglichkeiten den eigenen Charakter gestärkt hat.
Aber wie gesagt, das ist ein Trugschluss, für den wir mehr als veranlagt sind.
Und an diesem Punkt hab ich mich selbst erwischt.
Naja, es ist doch einfach auch so, dass die Leute, die jetzt Eltern sind, ihre Sachen
im Kopf als Maßstab haben.
So nach dem Motto Ja, das hat bei mir gut funktioniert oder vielleicht das hätte ich mir damals
gewünscht, das muss jetzt für mein Kind auch gut sein.
Dass es jetzt halt 30 Jahre später ist oder 35, 40 Jahre später ist, das musste halt
dann auch mal dran denken, dass sich die Zeiten geändert haben.
Ich wollte mich aus dieser Konklusion herauswieseln.
Ja, ich mache mir Sorgen über die Ideale, die Instagram-Feeds insbesondere Kindern vermitteln,
pädagogisch unbeaufsichtigten YouTube-Kanälen, die ihren Einfluss auf die Persönlichkeitsbildung
von Heranwachsenden ignorieren und vor Leuten, die das Internet mit ihrem zusammengesponnenen
konspirativen Blödsinn zumüllen.
Das sind doch alles echte Probleme, oder?
Oder waren ich gerade nur davor, viereckige Augen zu kriegen?
Wie wird die Zeit diese Befürchtungen beurteilen?
Wird eventuell in 20 Jahren ein Kanal namens Megalative Metaverse in den Kleinflächen
zwischen den Werbebanden...
Also, ich denke mal, dass es durchaus zu jeder Zeit an den Medien auch durchaus berechtigte
Kritik gab.
Es gab sicherlich berechtigte Kritik an Fernsehsendungen, an Büchern, an Radiosendungen oder sonst
was.
Da war sicherlich auch viel Schund dabei, die sicherlich auch viel fragwürdige Sachen
vermittelt haben.
Das ist halt auf TikTok, YouTube und sonst wie auch nicht anders.
Und sicherlich ist da viel Kack-Content dabei.
Keine Frage und ich denke auch nicht, dass alles davon jetzt wirklich gute Auswirkungen
auf die Leute haben wird.
Aber unterm Strich ist jetzt nicht unsere Jugend verloren, nur weil es heutzutage Instagram
gibt.
Und ganz im Ernst, wenn man einfach mal schlecht drauf sein will, klickt die Deutschen
Hashtags auf Twitter durch.
Das ist ja wirklich an Verzweiflung kaum noch zu überbieten.
Deutsche Twitter Hashtags, das ist der Wahnsinn.
Deswegen wohne ich auch nicht mehr in Deutschland auf Twitter, sondern in Andorra.
Ich kann mir die deutschen Twitter Trends...
Machen wir doch gerade mal den Spaß.
Wir gucken das jetzt nicht an.
Ich nur mal so vergleichen.
Also was haben wir denn hier zu bieten?
Marta, keine Ahnung, Preise, Tuchel, keine Ahnung, muss, muss, Dauerthema, Dauerthema,
das kann ich nicht aufmachen, weil wenn ich das aufmache, ist eh vorbei.
Bikini-Oberteil, Frau Schröder, Heizlüfter, Hitze, Chantal, Nagelspann, Atomkraftwerk,
Bundeswehr, Hitze, Tropfen, Wagner, Nachbarin, Heizlüfter, Rune, Rune, okay.
Das geht tatsächlich noch, es geht deutlich schlimmer, ich wollte gerade sagen, ist wirklich
noch ganz okay.
Da hat er recht zu dieses Hilfe die ganze Jugend ist verloren, weil TikTok ist doch
Schwachsinn.
Da hört ja auch keiner drauf, wenn du sowas, wenn du sowas blödes erzählst, dann sagt
die Jugend höchstens, ah, wieder so ein Typ, der es nicht versteht und da haben sie ja
auch recht mit.
Aber wenn man, sagen wir mal, halbwegs sinnvolle, begründete Sachen sagt, dann ist die Chance
zumindest auch höher, dass einem vielleicht ein paar Leute zuhören, weil die wissen,
okay, ganz ahnungslos scheint er nicht zu sein, wenn er das kennt.
Der große Konsens bei Pädagogen ist, dass Verbote vor unliebsamen Medien nicht dabei
helfen, ein gesundes Verhältnis zu ihnen aufzubauen, im Gegenteil, sie begünstigen
es viel mehr, dass das eigene Kind auch seine Nachkommen vor Neuerungen in der Medienwelt
warnt, einfach.
Also Verbote und Zwänge ist so ein allgemein so ein Ding, ich meine, das ist jetzt nicht
mein Bereich, aber wo ich mir nicht vorstellen kann, dass das irgendwie zur Entspannung führt.
Nehmen wir doch mal das aktuellste Thema, wo es darum ging, es müssen alle Leute, müssen
sich impfen lassen, ja, Impfzwang, das hat doch, das hätte im Leben nicht zur Entspannung
geführt.
Also weder bei Corona noch zur gesellschaftlichen, das hätte eher zur weiteren, ähm, ja, wie
soll ich sagen, Grenz verschärft, nee, wie soll ich sagen, so, ähm, Verhärtung geführt,
ja.
Ich bin da auch überhaupt kein Fan von, ich, wie gesagt, ich hab mich impfen lassen, aber
ich bin komplett gegen solche Entscheidungen von oben herab, wo man sagt, die Leute müssen
das machen.
Es gibt natürlich immer Grenzen, wo man sagt, ja, das ist sinnvoll, ja, zum Beispiel, dass
man sagt, hey, vielleicht ist es gut, dass wir nicht wie die Amis mit nem, mit nem M4
durchs Kaufhaus laufen, ja, würde ich, würde ich unterschreiben, ähm, aber es ist halt
immer eine Abwägungssache, zwischen wie viel Einfluss hat das, oder wie sehr schneidet
das, beschränkt das die Leute, und wie viel bringt das, und generell finde ich Verbote
oder, oder, oder, wie soll ich sagen, Verbote oder, ähm, ja, ähm, diese, diese, so, so
Vorschriften, immer das letzte, was man machen sollte, weil es meistens nicht zu dem führt,
was man sich erhofft.
Also, das ist auch ein, das ist auch ein Punkt, der mich die letzten Jahre über allgemein
ein bisschen nervt, diese Sache, sobald irgendwas einem nicht gefällt, kommen, kommen die Leute
dann um die Ecke so, oh, am besten gleich verbieten, aber es ist doch meistens gar nicht
die, die, das, das Problem, das was komplett verboten werden muss, meistens ist es doch
nur, dass irgendwas überverhältnismäßig nervt, wo man nicht sagen kann, ja, es muss
alles erlaubt sein, und ja, es muss alles verboten sein, es gibt ja Zwischen, es gibt
ja Zwischenschritte, ja, zum Beispiel, guckt euch mal an, ähm, wie das bei uns mit Lärmbelästigung
gemacht ist, ja, du darfst, auf deinem Kunststück, darfst du Rasen mähen, darfst du Zeug an
die Wand schrauben und alles, aber nicht zwischen 22 Uhr und, ähm, 7, oder so, 6,
also ja, natürlich, es ist nicht komplett verboten, dass du Krach machst auf deinem
Kunststück, aber nachts hast du gefälliges ruhig zu sein, und das sind eigentlich eher
so realitätsbezogene Sachen, die dann auch funktionieren, die dann auch irgendwie, den,
den Leuten einleuchten, das ist genauso, wenn an Silvester wieder heißt, oh, Feuerwerk,
ganz furchtbar schlimm, Umweltverschmutzung, Abfall, die armen Haustiere, ist alles, hat
alles durchaus Sachen, die ich, die ich nachvollziehen kann, ja, durchaus kann ich, kann ich alles
durchaus nachvollziehen, aber da ist doch nicht die logische Schlussfolgerung draus,
ja, man muss Feuerwerk verbieten, es ist, das ist doch, das ist doch eine alles, das
ist doch gar keine alles oder nichts Frage, es ist doch eher die Frage, können wir vielleicht
was dran ändern, wie es aktuell gemacht wird, also könnte man zum Beispiel sagen, ja, ähm,
vielleicht ist es nur an speziellen Orten erlaubt, oder vielleicht, der nächste Schritt,
vielleicht macht man das auch in eine Veranstaltung, dass die Stadt Feuerwerk macht, nicht mehr
individuell, da muss man sich halt mal überlegen, ok, was ist denn auf der, auf der Messlatte
zwischen 0 und 100, das was für viele Leute verdrehtbar ist, ja, was ist denn der Mittelweg,
wieso den Mittelweg, haben wir doch gefunden, der überwiegende Teil der Leute war insofern
einsichtig, hat gesagt, ja, ich lass mich impfen, das hat doch eigentlich alles ganz
gut funktioniert, weil der nächste Punkt, und warum ich persönlich gegen, ja, wie soll
ich sagen, Impfzwang oder so bin es, musst du dir überlegen, was ist denn der nächste
Punkt, was machst du denn mit Leuten, wenn du sagst, ja, ihr müsst euch impfen lassen
und die machen es nicht, was machst du dann, wenn du A sagst, musst du B sagen und du
willst B nicht sagen in diesem Fall, du willst garantiert nicht B sagen, weil B sagen bedeutet,
du musst entweder Strafe bezahlen oder die Polizei holt dich ab und du kriegst das Ding
in den Arm gerammt und das willst du beides nicht haben, das ist natürlich total, ja,
der Extremfall, aber wenn du A sagst, du willst einen Zwang einführen und die Leute halten
sich nicht dran, brauchst du eine Antwort, was machst du, wenn sie sich nicht dran halten,
was willst du machen und da gibt's, finde ich, keine verträgliche Antwort drauf und
ich finde, wir haben es eigentlich ganz gut hingekriegt, ich persönlich, für mich hab
gesagt, ich finde das sinnvoll zu machen und wer weiß, wie schlimm meine Corona-Infektion
gewesen wäre, wäre ich nicht 3 mal geimpft, wenn man jetzt die Leute glaubt, die das alles
bescheuert finden, die würden zu mir sagen, Max, das wäre genauso verlaufen, überhaupt
nichts Schlimmes, ist doch eh nur Erkältung, ja, oder die anderen haben gesagt, ja wie,
warum hast du dich noch nicht 4 mal impfen lassen oder sonst wie, also ich hab's gemacht
im Rahmen, wie ich das für mich am sinnvollsten halte und ich finde, diese eigenverantwortliche
Entscheidung, das muss man eben unterstreichen nochmal, naja, komm, und das ist wirklich
dein Argument, für das du Leute dazu zwingen willst, also deine persönliche Unversehrtheit
und deine persönliche Entscheidung keine Nadel in den Arm zu wollen, ist ja wohl auch
persönliche Freiheit, also ich kenne das, ich verstehe beide Seiten in gewisser Weise,
deswegen ist das einzige, was man sinnvoll machen kann, finde ich das, was wir gemacht
haben, zu sagen, das muss jeder selbst entscheiden und dann ist gut und dementsprechend muss
auch jeder selbst damit leben, was passiert, hätte ich mich jetzt nicht impfen lassen,
hätte Corona gekriegt und es wäre richtig beschissen, nee eigentlich nicht, eigentlich
habe ich da gar keinen Bock mehr drauf, weil der Chat schon wieder anfängt und es wäre
richtig beschissen, dann hätte ich nicht sagen können so nach dem Motto, ah ja, hier, hättet
ihr mich mal mehr dazu bringen müssen, nee, da hätte ich wirklich sagen müssen, nein,
es ist meine Entscheidung gewesen, es nicht zu machen, also habe ich jetzt gelitten oder
umgedreht, ich habe mich dafür entschieden und ich muss auch mit den Konsequenzen leben,
das ist die einzig sinnvolle Sache, die wir machen konnten, finde ich, ja wir gucken das
Video weiter, also was anderes hätten wir gar nicht machen können, ich finde das tatsächlich
ganz gut, wie wir das gehandhabt haben, das nämlich einfach gut sein lassen, so wie es
ist, so, aber wir kommen jetzt bis fertig, ok, du hast recht und ich will nicht, also
ich bin froh für jeden, der im Pflegeberuf Arbeit und diesen Scheiß noch macht, muss
ich sagen, aber man muss es an der Stelle auch mal wirklich nüchtern, äh nüchtern
betrachten, als IT Mensch musst du dich auch jeden Tag mit unfähigen Leuten auseinandersetzen
und ja, du musst dich als Pfleger um Idioten kümmern, das ist halt so und ich kann verstehen,
dass diesen Kack keiner mehr machen will bei der Bezahlung, bei der psychischen Belastung
und bei dem Stress, den du hast, aber ja, es ist halt Teil des Jobs in dem Fall und es
ist jetzt ja auch nicht so, als wären wir irgendwie da kurz vorm Zusammenbruch gewesen,
dann hätte man sich da was überlegen können, aber ich hab eigentlich gesagt, auf das Thema
überhaupt kein Bock mehr und Großeltern, je nachdem von welcher Seite die Sorgen ausgehen
und das Ganze kann natürlich auch ins andere Extrem verdreht werden, übermäßiger Optimismus
kann genauso dämlich sein, das stimmt, das stimmt, es gibt auch Leute, die es total übertreiben
und sich beispielsweise Smart Locks einbauen und sich dann wundern, ah über die China-Chinesen-App
kann man jetzt mal eine Tür aufmachen, eh, NFT's, NFT's, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja,
ja, ja, NFT's, NFT's, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja.
in dem wir uns das vorstellen.
Hat er recht, war ein gutes Video.
Trefft eigentlich nämlich genau das, was ich auch über dieses Thema denke.
Hups, warum macht er so einen lauten Krach?
Jetzt gut Leute, lass das Thema bleiben.
Ich hätte davor gar nicht anfangen sollen.
Ich bin da nur drauf eingestiegen, weil der Chat angefangen hat.
Giga-Chat, Chat.
Quatsch, ich bann keinen. Für was soll ich euch bann, Leute? Der Chat ist so...
So feif hat normalerweise, ich bann hier kein.
Einzige Leute, die ich banne sind, die Links zu irgendwelchen komischen Scam-Seiten posten,
was wir jetzt schon ein paar Mal hatten in den letzten Wochen.
Das zu den Amazon-Reviews, das kenn ich.
TikTok-Videos, nein, ich gucke keine TikTok-Videos.
Jetzt nicht, keine TikTok-Videos.
Ich habe übrigens auch am Anfang von YouTube, habe ich einen Fehler gemacht.
Ich dachte, die Leute sind nicht so blöd.
Und zwar, ich habe am Anfang von YouTube keine Leute gebannt und keine Comments gelöscht,
weil ich als alter Hacker-Man, Meinungsfreiheit und jeder soll sagen, was er will und so.
Das wollte ich da hochhalten auf meinem YouTube-Channel.
Das Problem ist nur gewesen, dass dort so viel Krütze dabei war von den Leuten damals.
Da war ja wirklich auch Dinge, die fast schon strafbar waren, was da teilweise gepostet wurde.
Irgendwann habe ich mir gedacht, nee, du musst manche Leute einfach bannen.
Und gerade Leute, die mich persönlich abgefuckt haben, die quasi nichts Besseres zu tun hatten,
als Kommentare unter die Videos zu schreiben, nur um mich zu ärgern, da habe ich mir gedacht,
weißt du was, wir sind hier nicht demokratisch auf YouTube, wir sind hier auf meinem YouTube-Channel
und wenn es mir auf den Sack geht, dann banne ich euch einfach.
Fertig.
Das mache ich heute noch so.
Wenn es irgendwas gibt, wo ich merke und gerade was mich richtig triggert,
wenn Leute was schreiben, so sinngemäß irgendwie, ah Max, bei 3 Minuten 50, das und das und das
und das, die schreiben ein halbwegs sinnvolles Kommentar und man denkt so irgendwie,
ja, vielleicht haben sie es nicht ganz verstanden und du antwortest denen dann drauf,
ja, aber guck doch mal, eine Minute später spreche ich doch genau das an, was du gesagt hast,
antwortest ihm dann drauf und dann kommt als Antwort irgendwie so ein richtig dummer Shit.
Da banne ich die Leute dann immer weg.
Wenn ich mir denke, ich habe mir jetzt schon Mühe gegeben auf deinen ersten schwachsinnigen Kommentar
zu antworten und dir fällt nichts besseres ein, wie das mit einem noch schwachsinnigeren Kommentar
zu beantworten, dann banne ich die Leute immer weg mittlerweile.
Dieser Typ beim Telekom Gaming Router, da kann ich mich nicht, da habe ich doch keinen gebannt.
Die Musik dazu, ja, passt richtig.
Nee, also, da habe ich mich irgendwann davon abgeschminkt, dass das irgendwie so eine,
ja, so demokratisches Miteinander in YouTube-Kommentaren, so jeder soll was schreiben und was er will.
Nein, das ist bei mir auf dem YouTube-Channel nicht so.
Wenn du mich abfuckst, banne ich dich ganz einfach.
Und hier im Chat ist es ähnlich, zum Glück haben wir hier keine Leute, die es darauf anlegen.
Wenn wir wirklich, wenn ihr wirklich, doch, wir haben manchmal Leute, die sind nur da, um mich zu ärgern.
Und da habe ich, da habe ich echt keinen Nerv drauf, das muss ich mir nicht geben.
Richtig und wichtig ist auch so eine Redewendung, die...
Es gibt so, es gibt so ein paar Sachen, die nerven mich.
Richtig und wichtig gehört auf jeden Fall dabei.
Nee, hier ist keine Demokratie.
Also prinzipiell auf Twitch schonmal eh nicht, weil Twitch kann uns alle bannen, ohne dass irgendwas passiert.
Und auf dem Channel auch nicht.
Also ich meine, ich versuche natürlich jetzt keine Leute hier für Kleinigkeiten zu bannen.
Aber wenn es einer wiederholt nicht lassen kann, ja, dann muss er halt woanders gucken.
Absolut.
ehemaliger battlefield entwickler packt aus da habe ich schon ein paar ausgepackt
und ein paar haben das beste also den besten post den einer ehemaliger dies entwickler gemacht
hat war weiß ich ob ihr das gelesen habt noch ganz kurz den letzten fünf minuten kann ich
es kann ich das ja kann ich das mal schnell erzählen ein ehemaliger dies mit dabei der
glaub an battlefield eins noch mitentwickelt hat hat hat sich darüber geäußert ne tensor flow kam
noch nicht gucken wir uns gucken wir uns nichts waren aber das muss ich jetzt kurz mal erzählen
der hat einen post gemacht wie so die abweitsweise bei dies intern gewesen ist und da wundert mich
da wundert mich echt nichts mehr da ging es darum um irgendwelche ich weiß gar nicht
was es genau war um irgendwelche features die in dem spiel drinne waren oder irgendwelche
mechaniken die in dem spiel drinne waren die er halt für ziemlich unsinnig hielt beziehungsweise
für nicht ja nicht battlefield like oder nicht spaßig für den spieler und das hat er halt
angesprochen in irgendeinem intern meeting oder in einem intern meetings chat war das glaube
sogar und daraufhin wurde sich nicht darüber unterhalten ob dieses feature sinnvoll ist
beziehungsweise das feature sich noch mal gedanken drüber gemacht sondern er hat einen anschiss vom
moderator bekommen wie er das überhaupt wagen kann in einem öffentlichen chat das feature zu
kritisieren was jemand anderes eingebaut hat weil da könnte er sich an seinen gefühlen verletzt
fühlen da ich war auch gedacht meine güte über drei zeit mal nicht das ist das andere das ist echt
das andere extrem ja auf der einen seite wenn die leute teilweise krass ausgebeutet bis zum geht nicht
mehr und die man jetzt sowas können wir nicht irgendwie so gesundes gesundes mittelmaß machen
so nach dem motto wir behandeln die leute nicht wie scheiße aber wir packen auch nicht alle in
watte also sowas sowas normales zwischendurch sowas irgendwie was wo man effektiv und und und
so sagen wir so produkt orientiert arbeiten kann so was normales einfach also habe ich mir auch
gedacht also jetzt haben sie es jetzt weiß ich auch nicht was was da los ist ja dann wundert mich in
battle field 2042 ja auch nichts mehr wenn so die features entstanden sind man sieht es am
handy wie lange der stream läuft sehr prog würde ich dazu sagen oder sehr moment wie
wird man kann jason anders als jason aussprechen das war mir noch gar nicht bewusst ok was für
aussprachen von jason kennt ihr jason jason was jason das sagt doch niemand
josen jason jason jason leute tschibet sagt doch niemand ok moment der hatte jemand der
hatte den partner der chip morningstar hieß alter das ist ja der krasseste namen den ich je
gehört habe was jismol was gonna be the morningstar partner chip morningstar das hört sich an wie irgendein superheld oder so was jismol was gonna be the javascript message language and jismol is just a terrible name but fortunately it turned out that
sun had already created a standard called jismol so it's like okay good we're not gonna use that one and so we spent about two minutes
streit mit sun willst du nicht haben
what else could it be and we came up with javascript object notation and that's what it was and we called it jason
ja jason ist doch alles gut jason it didn't occur to us that you could call anything else and then years later we found almost everybody was saying jason
ja das ist ja kaum ein unterschied nicht so wie jiff jiff oder oder gift was was wie kommt
dann jetzt darauf ne ne ne leut wirklich nicht wirklich nicht es mag ja erfinder sein aber
nee nee irgendwann ist auch mal gut jason nee nee nee nee muss ich alles muss ich alles machen nur meine erfinderung sagt
okay leute alles klar wir sehen uns beim nächsten stream ich gehe jetzt pennen bettgetime bis dann macht's gut co